there's no time o clock hey everybody
episode 196 Thomson wait for this one
he's buried yeah yeah we were talking
about [ __ ] you know the supernatural
the supernatural yeah yeah he's been
bugging me to do this one for a while so
if I moved it we're gonna talk about
what's natural what's not natural what's
supernatural what's superhuman human
abilities and just you know about the
physical culture that we're gonna talk
about and this is actually a very
interesting story but it has a lot of
interesting [ __ ] crazy characters in
this yet
yeah it's not boring at all some people
go I want to listen in Jim ratchet I was
kind of like that until I you know got a
little bit older and started to
appreciate more things you know Amanda
[ __ ] and once I figured out who these
dudes were where all this [ __ ] came from
it's quite interesting well I'm always
kind of interested in the history of
things that I never really thought about
the history of yeah you know what I mean
so it's like this initially this seemed
like a topic I was just kind of like
yeah whatever but you know I was I ended
up I found myself watching like a
two-hour BBC documentary yeah I think
that came out in 2015 so it's five years
old and it talked about like the history
like a body building from like the
earliest days and stuff like that I want
a substitute to the present day or at
least till 2015 and it was actually
really interesting and like they talked
like they interviewed like all the main
guys and you know talked about this that
the other thing and it was just like a
really fascinating you know discussion
about something that I knew very little
about other than you know what you talk
about
sometimes cuz you kind of like him it's
a subculture it's a it's it's
biotechnology is philosophy and it's men
just being competitive [ __ ] you know
how they are
yeah and [ __ ] when you start getting
and when you start
when you start going into the history of
all these characters and like I follow a
lot of them on YouTube and Instagram and
even if I can listen to the kick in the
light and then she ran off and then you
know uh characters like Leroy Colbert
you know he had you know he had he's
passed away but all his videos are still
up and and he would tell all these
stories about what they would do in the
gym back in the 50s like jerking off for
money and [ __ ] doing weird [ __ ] and
having sex with women that would just
walk into the back in the 50s there were
women that would go to a damn gym to
walk in there and have sex with muscle
men of all different colors interesting
yeah there was like they would like
gangbang these suckin groupies and you
wouldn't think that but that was like in
the 50s of LA there's all kinds of weird
[ __ ] that was another Wikipedia page no
I used to have these weird competitions
where they'd all start throwing money on
the ground and jerking off and whoever
whoever busted or not first and be able
to get that big pile of money see I've
heard that like different though that
it's like they jerk off on a cookie in
the middle and whoever is the first or
the last they had to eat it yes no bear
said Colbert said it was no I know might
take a different variation yeah if they
did it did it for money and [ __ ]
dudes we're trying to we're practicing
to see who could bust another fastest
because sometimes that pile of money was
like over a hundred bucks and that would
help pay rent yeah you know and so they
were trying to get that kitty and
sometime they were witnesses you know
women were watching and [ __ ] like that
evidently it was just weird [ __ ] that
they did and it's because of you know
the weird things that [ __ ]
testosterone and [ __ ]
performance-enhancing drugs does to the
mind I guess you know although he didn't
really mention performance-enhancing
drugs until later I don't know exactly
what era this was all you needs
testosterone testosterone it's like yeah
very dangerous and they were young yes
they were doing that they were young
guys they were teenagers so you know
yeah they're in there let the teenager
you're like in their late teens
yeah that I understand I don't know why
but that seems like an idea at a teenage
men everywhere I like me Roy's videos
you know he's just a friendly he was he
was a friends with Arnold Schwarzenegger
and he never he claims to have never
taken any steroids and probably didn't
he's a motorcycle rider lost his damn
foot crushed his foot up and Joe Weider
made put him in charge of a bunch of
shows Joe Weider actually kind of
adopted him as a son in a way he would
he was kind of abandoned by his dad yeah
and so Joe kind of raised him and he was
just this big friendly really evidently
really talkative black dude leave really
everybody said that it was just bust on
him for talking too much he's to talk
constantly but he owned a little vitamin
stores and [ __ ] but you know watch Leroy
Leroy is Leroy Colbert's a trip all this
videos are still up there he died a few
years back ended a lot of his video a
lot ended a lot of his videos with a
clip of him slamming a door look I quit
this [ __ ] and he's like he's like
[ __ ] 70 something years old the guy's
hilarious quit this [ __ ] [ __ ] like he
left the damn leaving his damn vitamin
store that's but you know these are not
only most of these guys are not just big
guys they're big [ __ ] characters they
had personalities hell yeah and he goes
to match that's why they became
bodybuilders bodybuilders I you know
they are athletes but it's not really a
sport because it's all subjective you
know what I mean it's just whatever the
judge is like that's a damn beauty
contest when you think about yeah I mean
that's why and that's why they're still
cuz I think there's been like an ongoing
thing where they're trying to get
bodybuilding put into the Olympics but I
believe they have not been successful up
to this point because people are arguing
it's not really a sport like there's a
core yeah it's more of an aesthetic
judgment it's like a beauty contest
right kind of maybe not maybe even less
maybe even more shallow I want to say
yeah then a beauty contest
they have to say
those women had to like sing yeah comedy
or like you know and have like
interviews and stuff these guys just
have to stay in there and like clench
their yeah it's just how big are you and
[ __ ] how cool do you look and how
scare do you look or how handsome you
you know it's all subjective and that's
imagery that's a big yes symmetry it all
depends on what the judge is like so you
know you can't score that yeah you're
not I mean is it this objective
subjective yeah so it's more of an art
than anything I think it's very close to
hot rodding yeah hot rodding cars
doesn't involve crossing finish lines or
anything like that it's just taking
their badass car to a show and judge is
going I like that car yeah you know I
mean look at a big [ __ ] scoop
sticking out of the hood I like the
paint job that's what they're doing it's
just men and it's very male oriented the
[ __ ] talent [ __ ] being able to talk or
it's just what do you look like yeah
very visual yeah like I said so in that
sense it's even less like Hershell
substance America cause like all those
like beauty pageants but before we start
to show I guess a that's kind of
[ __ ] because personality was a
factor it's just that they didn't look
for instance the greatest bodybuilder of
all times it's gonna be Arnold
Schwarzenegger yeah but there were times
when he won competitions when he
shouldn't want him there were guys that
looked better than him sometime well
wasn't there in 1980 there was a big
[ __ ] yeah there was yes scandal
there's no way he could have won that
one there was guys that looked a lot
better than well and he wasn't gonna
enter and then he entered like the last
minute like the night before yes Joe had
a lot to do with that [ __ ] yeah dude
that was about that on that be a
documentary I think it happened again in
1981 not with Arnold Schwarzenegger but
with somebody else
yeah and so like a lot of um I think
like the year after that like a lot of
the bodybuilders wouldn't compete
because they were so pissed off about
how unfair it was that Arnie had come in
and like said oh I'm not gonna compete
I'm not gonna compete
oh yeah I am gonna compete like the very
last possible second and then he ended
up winning
yeah you look good but he didn't look at
a lot of but a lot of people thought
that he shouldn't have one yeah he
shouldn't want it there were other guys
that looked that looked a lot better in
that particular competition I mean he
hadn't competed I think in two or three
years he just shot that guy and and so
really personality and charisma was a
factor it's just that you know I mean
like and they they just they didn't
person and charisma was a factor it's
just that you couldn't rely on it Arnie
could yeah but what I think hi the
scenes mattered if they didn't like you
you weren't gonna win yeah so cuz there
were guys that were looked good but they
didn't like them yeah behind the scenes
you know they were dicks they're you
know I mean so they it's the same with
getting a job or anything like that it's
not always the best person for the job
or the person with the most experience
it's the people that they like the most
because they're like well we're gonna
have to hang out with this person
everyday so so popularity was also part
of it you have to think too that are
that Arnold Schwarzenegger and Lou
Ferrigno to a slightly lesser extent
they were kind of the two guys that
because they got so famous that sort of
made bodybuilding more a mainstream type
of thing that's a lot of that's a lot of
the reasons why they want yeah okay
because it's not so much what they did
on stage it's what they did for that
entire scene and Arnie made that Arnold
made that a mainstream scene that a
housewife would know about yeah and
that's not the way it was before
well yeah very like yeah it was a souca
but he took that [ __ ] to the big screen
and it became a household concept they
had like tons of different like
competitions and the prize money went
way up and all this other kind of stuff
too because holy crapola she's running
up today so I think like they had a lot
to do with that like that getting so
famous yeah so before we start the show
is there anything we have to do here I
just have one shout out because we don't
have any new patrons or anything like
that this week boo
and I already shouted I shouted him out
on one of the side track shows but
like I said I always like to do on the
main show as well I'd like to thank our
friend Rob Levinson who sent us yet
another movie and this was one that I
was very excited about this is sexy
beast yeah for UK crime movie which I
think I saw in the theater if I'm
remembering I don't see it's a really
really good because he said he sent it
because we had talked about how we liked
Bronson so much and he's like oh there's
another like British crime movie and I
had seen it but you haven't seen it and
I haven't seen it for many years but
yeah I'm excited to like watch it again
cuz I remember really liking it a lot um
I can't remember it's based on a real
story I thought it was based on a real
guy but I can't remember exactly but I
remember really liking it a lot but I
think that was the only shout out that
we had so we can get into talking about
now um now when we talk about body
building I don't know if like people
that don't know about it it's like it's
not weightlifting that's a different
drug weightlifting right is a sport in
the sense that you know how much weight
can you lift it's also not the same
thing as like [ __ ] like the strongman
competitions which is essentially just
like you know hey I can lift a car yeah
I can pull a car with my teeth or all
the old tractor tires or and [ __ ] like
although bodybuilders do do those right
but that's insane
yeah is saying like going to the Olympia
you know I mean mr. Olympia is like it's
like like a beauty contest like mr.
America you know or Miss Universe it's
basically you just go you try to either
get as big or symmetrical or whatever
you do oh let's do all these posing
routine and then it's just like an
aesthetic appreciation yeah and then
like one of the one of the things about
physical culture or weightlifter
bodybuilding culture if you go online a
lot of you used to be in Hollywood a lot
but it you know its popularity waned in
recent years you know Arnold and those
guys that their movies soon he got older
the movies started to move on to other
things you know I think you know kidding
they were replaced with kinou reeves and
guys like that you know I mean in terms
of for action roles but oh [ __ ] I forgot
I was gonna say
[Laughter]
oh if you go a lot of this moved on to
Instagram that's what I was gonna say
yeah and and it's moved on into YouTube
and guys coaching and making YouTube
videos of them at the gym and then you
know I mean they all they're they're
still making money they just do it in a
different way all right well if you look
in the comments sections one of the one
of the big things going on is like is
this dude natural or is he enhanced you
know has he been taking steroids and
that's always the big debate natural or
not okay there ladies this guy natural
he's not natural because there's a lot
of what they call fake Nattie's and
that's a guy who is modified he's been
enhanced through performance-enhancing
drugs and he claims to be natural and he
does this because he wants you to buy
his supplements as usually like protein
powder or pre-workout drink you know and
he's basically insinuating that he got
built like this with this product that
he's selling you all right that's
[ __ ] that's not how he got that got
to stay on the grift okay okay but a lot
of them are kind of like semi obvious
about it or like no I'm taking other
things but you as a new guy who doesn't
want to take steroids this will help you
so that's kind of like how they get
around that you can read in between the
lines that that's kind of what they're
saying a lot of times yeah some guys are
a little more straight up about it like
Greg do set like coach Greg I like him
because he's straight up honest about
everything he'll tell you you know what
works what doesn't work what's arms are
what [ __ ] steroids are he'll tell
everything you tell you everything you
know he'll tell you he's on them you
know so it's kind of moving into the
direction of honesty nowadays but
there's a lot of people who are new to
this and they are always trying to
figure out who's natural and who's not
natural and really that's when kind of
like they start getting out of the
subject of well what is possible without
performance-enhancing drugs
it's difficult to know nowadays because
a lot of guys are lying about what
they're taking yeah so to find out the
truth you got to go back into the past
before steroids and
performance-enhancing drugs existed so
if you can see the guys that exist where
around before performance-enhancing
drugs you can say well that's what's
possible yeah on your own which brings
us back to the very grandfather of all
this Eugen Sandow yeah when you win the
Olympia competition they give you a damn
statue and it's called the Sandow award
and it's a statue of Eugen Sandow stand
there what cast naked I think I might
have a [ __ ] fig leaf with with a
single long wait you know it's gonna I
not wanted I found yeah I found that you
can rest assured that he was nabbed that
he was in Maddy all right but in a
standards he was still world well-built
yeah he didn't have yet big arms a big
army didn't have a big chest that's
because they didn't have benchpress back
then but and he didn't really work out
by today's standards his his show his
routine he did on stage was his workout
really he did it like once a day and and
he told people you know what he did he
[ __ ] slept like [ __ ] 15
hours a day
he claimed you know 88 a lot of [ __ ]
protein and sold naked selfies you know
that's probably what he did and sold
little tupou weights and tell people
that they'd get big if they [ __ ] curl
dip to pound weight which was [ __ ]
sold a lot of [ __ ] books which helped
a little bit but he also sold tobacco
and coffee said that'll make you strong
to he'll say yeah cuz man gotta eat
you know you sell [ __ ] he was a great
showman and he was Russia and Eugen
Sandow was the beginning of fitness as
we know it military's adopted a lot of
his training to keep their soldiers fit
like push-ups and sit-ups so let's begin
with that yeah you want to start with
that yeah cuz I feel like bodybuilding
didn't really come about in any sort of
like codified sort of way until I
along because prior to that you know
even though yes in you know ancient
Greece and Rome and stuff like that they
did have you know at least from the
statues and at least from like you know
written accounts and things like that
they did have sort of a physical culture
where people would like lift stones and
things like that like to get into shape
so they didn't know about that yeah but
modern people didn't believe it though
yeah but you know I I don't know why
they wouldn't I mean it doesn't seem
like a terribly hard thing to evidently
in even in the 1800s for thousands of
years your people had were looking at
greco-roman statues yeah
statues of Zeus and statues of like the
pugilistic of like heroes and for
thousand years people thought that that
was [ __ ] that people couldn't be
built that way that it was an idealized
figure Eugene Eugene saw that and he
thought that that might have been
possible so he was taking those statues
and taking proportional measurements for
of them and trying to figure out if he
could get his body to be shaped like
that and eventually he did let me prove
that no they did have biotechnology in
other words they knew about sports
medicine they knew how to workout and
get big whatever methods they used
probably have not survived yeah over the
times because in medieval 's weren't
doing it you know I don't think their
priorities and their diet could have
supported it no Rome was always
emulating Greece and I think in Rome he
actually took that that science to even
greater extent according to what it
survived so and because they were more
wealthy than the ancient Greeks because
they were part of an empire they could
probably have better diets and they had
a culture of going to these baths and
bath houses and walking around naked and
mixed company and looking good the old
idea was just to look [ __ ] good yeah
kinda like going to hip-hip-hip and him
a beach you know down and under Brazil
the nudity wasn't a problem in Rome so
they showed their [ __ ] off so evidently
based on
those statues they must have and the
idea of [ __ ] sports medicine and what
was happening in the in the arena you
know with gladiators and acrobats and
armies they knew about training and
physical training they knew about even
how to repair wounds from combat they
must have had what we would know as
weight sets yeah okay and those are
actually a new invention the idea to
having weights with you know plates on
it you can make heavier and heavier sand
I didn't really have those he had kind
of the molded ones yeah they were like
cast it was usually a bar with spheres
on the end of it yeah I'm each one with
a bigger and bigger and bigger sphere so
you couldn't fine tune it by five pounds
or ten pounds as it went up or down yeah
a lot of times he only had a few of them
yeah you know you because they were
expensive they were custom jobs and they
didn't have a bench that you could lay
down on and do bench presses if you look
at Sandow you see his chest isn't as
well press it seems obvious now but that
was a much later much later envision
they did other weird things where they
would pick something up in one hand and
get underneath it or weird things that
they had to bar above their head but
that you just I can't I can't even
imitate the lift [ __ ] that didn't look
like it would do anything like you hold
the bar straight up and then you go down
and he the bar is in the same place but
you're going up and down instead of
doing this yeah you're holding the bar
straight and you are going up and down I
don't know how effective that would be
yeah well him like it would be very not
effective but they were dealing with
heavy weight for the time and you could
build a better body than just some dude
yeah yeah and I mean because those guys
are [ __ ] scrawny and they didn't
really have the nutrition but let's get
into the deal yeah I mean and I feel
like even like starting at the very end
you know of the 19th century when you
had like you know we we met it went into
it a little bit on our show about like
circus sideshows and some like that were
they a lot of strongman but the thing
about the strongman was that they
weren't really a lot of them were just
kind of like they just had big arms and
they were strong they didn't they
weren't like doing anything but yeah
some of them were like kind of chubby or
like they were just big dudes like some
of the dudes you see
strongman competitions nowadays and they
would just do [ __ ] like you know pick up
the bar with the dwarves on the end or
ya know tear phone books in half of that
kind of crap so it but because I guess
you gents and Oh can't came out of that
scene because he went around to
carnivals and so because that was just
kind of what you did you know if that
was your talent back then he just went
around the circus and you know sideshows
and like displayed your feats of
strength and everything but he seemed to
be the first person to really have this
idea of displaying his body or trying to
get like the the ideal like his body to
look in an ideal fashion like the
greco-roman statues and then just kind
of would go around and pose and let
people like look at it he was also the
first guy he had a manager Florenz
Ziegfeld who I guess is the same person
responsible for the Ziegfeld Follies
like ask your great-grandma if you don't
know about that but you know all the
dancers like the kick guy kick and
dancers and all that but he was the
first he had like um the first one to
get into like marketing he would like
sell pictures of himself like posing
like naked like I said he just liked it
had a fig leaf on I found like a whole
[ __ ] time photo of him he had like
pamphlets you know about how like how to
lift weights and stuff
he sold his own like branded exercise
you know equipment yeah like I said the
little barbells and like my barbell was
just bullying in it yeah like [ __ ] like
that and his method okay I analyzed his
his training method it wouldn't have
worked
okay he was selling people to pound
weights a set of him and you squeezed
him and you basically did bench or he
did curls with it and you squeezed it as
it went up but it didn't really weigh
anything and then you would do stuff
like this and squeeze him like an
overhead press that communitary press
type deal and he was talking about doing
hundreds of reps with that all right
would take a long not only would have
taken a long time it would probably burn
muscle off of you yeah okay
only two pounds yeah yeah but I think
what the reason why I was doing that is
because he was selling these after his
shows you could carry a lot of them yeah
all right so you could sell a lot of
them make a lot of money but you can
carry you know yeah it's not like you
wanted to like bring a whole [ __ ]
thing like 50 hundred pounds yeah some
[ __ ] 30 pound foot to 30 pound
barbells you couldn't carry enough of
them but I think what he probably
rationalized it as that it was better
than nothing
well and and you were I'm not sure not
sure I think it was more about bringing
the awareness of fitness to people yeah
and I think a lot of the customers might
have been female that we're doing that
yeah
because evidently females came to see
him a lot you know the show oh yeah
because it might have been more kind of
like the original Chippendales type I
was gonna say that was like the [ __ ]
early 20th century version of like Magic
Mike reception yeah he get big on two on
two pound [ __ ] bar well anyway she's
like pictures of him and I found like a
like I said I found a [ __ ] ton of
photographs of him because that he was
like really really famous in his day and
he was known for like selling these like
cards and like little booklets and stuff
that had like pictures of him in it and
he was always posing and stuff so yeah I
mean he had like a pretty respectable
looking arms even though now it is you
get big from destroying muscle tissue
yeah
if repetitions made you big and strong
then guys who just worked in restaurants
and waitresses would all be huge because
that's all they do is just move around
all day yeah but they don't get big they
just burn up a lot of calories yeah you
gain a lot more from just like one
single super heavy lift that's done just
in a few seconds then you do have a
whole day of just walking around it's
one single highly concentrated output of
power that just [ __ ] up muscle you
don't get Vig from that because you
actually get weaker from that because
your muscle fibers are all torn up but
then you sit back and heal up for a
couple days
and after all that healing up you're a
little bit bigger a little bit stronger
than you were before
yeah you just repeat rinse and repeat do
that over every face you'll get better
it's basically just tearing your muscles
up and having healed and then had them
heal back up and then you're
progressively adding more weight so over
time those lifts involve a heavier
weight than it was last month until
eventually you peak out yeah and then
you take steroids and do more okay and
then he becomes about five years to
reach your [ __ ] potential and then
after you want him to get any bigger
than that then you're gonna require
[ __ ] outside support yeah even if
you're young and with the advent of
anabolic switch the show will eventually
get into in 18 months you can do what
would normally take [ __ ] 10 years to
do you can do it in 18 months
Anna Boch it's absolutely it was at the
time that all that came out that was
like Super Soldier Serum it was super
natural people couldn't believe it but
you pay for it it's not good for you
yeah [ __ ] your kidneys up well that's it
there's never anything such thing is
there's never any such thing as a free
run no like anything that seems like
magical and wonderful and anything like
that it's gonna kick your ass um yeah
there's a difference between abuse and
use though doctors prescribe it to heal
yeah and some people have who have used
it in doses that were low enough to
really you're not really getting the
supernatural results but you're getting
good results
yeah not I mean you so there's always
kind of middle paths and therapeutic
doses and [ __ ] but still you're not
natural if you do that yeah that's
called enhancement yeah another man
which we'll get to yeah but yeah so
Sando was actually the person that
organized the first official
bodybuilding contest this took place in
1901 at the Royal Albert Hall in London
Sandow did not compete in it obviously
because that he would have what that
would been cheating yeah but so he was
one of the judges and also one of the
one of the other judges was Sir Arthur
Conan Doyle hmm so you
hey miss people all around called the
great competition a great competition
that's what they called it yeah I miss
funny when you see the guys in the great
competition there's photos of it yeah
they're just regular guys I would have
won the great competition well this is
1901 yeah nobody was really like yeah
they weren't working out they weren't
working out they were just guys that
maybe we're like Lumberjacks so they
were [ __ ] lifted stuff inside of a
factory yeah but they were head and
shoulders above the average man of that
time yeah but it's kind of funny there
if you guys want a cease and al you
should probably put up some photos up
I've got to yeah I got and there's also
uh you might be able to craft in some
there's some film of him from the
Smithsonian Institute now I have to find
that black and white him doing his
routine in it it is opposing routine
it's it's very antiquated you know I
mean it's not quite as smooth this a guy
today would do it but I think that's
where the routine came from he wanted to
be shot in shadows so you can see his
definition and doing it really ahead of
the [ __ ] curve way ahead of the curve
way ahead of the curve I mean it almost
seems like he would be impressive today
yeah and it seems like it almost kind of
came out of nowhere I mean I know
nothing does and I'm sure he probably
got the idea from somewhere else but it
really does seem like almost all of the
modern stuff that people know about
bodybuilding
like all of the you know the branded
products and like just hims like selling
pictures of himself like magazines and
stuff like that with his picture on it
um he did all that [ __ ] well he caused a
breakthrough yeah because people saw
this Greek statues and thought that was
[ __ ] he just showed up and go man as
possible so and there was other guys
around that time that we're starting to
do it too
yeah Bobby Pandora was another one who I
think he might have been a little I
think he lived at the same time I
believe are we gonna talk about him at
all I don't remember if he's in my notes
er I think Bobby Pandora was a little
bit later but they did live together
they did live in the same time period if
I remember correctly he was a little bit
bigger but but Eugene was was before he
was the one that really did and he shows
up and he actually looks like that
people were impressed so it you know of
course it's gonna start snowballing
people
I'm gonna do that too yeah because it
must be said that when he came out I
mean he was hugely hugely famous when he
did when he organized the first
bodybuilding competition in the Royal
Albert Hall which is like not a small
venue it was like so it was packed they
had to turn people away because of all
the people that showed up to it he got
famous for basically uh punking out
[ __ ] strongmen yeah he would go to
assembly go to a strong men's act a
strong men at that time they wore these
damn furs we had to go like shoreland
stones I look like a wild man or
something like a caveman you know and
they would lift stuff but it wasn't all
that heavy and they had tricks to make
it harder to lift like the handles on
things would be like really fat like the
size of a coke can
which made stuff a little bit harder to
lift you could it it took it to practice
to learn how to lift something that was
a little bit larger diameter well sad
that would show up and watch this guy do
his routine and a lot of times it was
kind of part of a straw man's routine is
to challenge people in the audience to
try to lift it yeah and you didn't be
out there in a damn suit ok so you
really couldn't see how big he was
and then he accept the challenge and
when the guy would tell him to cope on
stage he it was a special suit that he
could rip away like a stripper oh
[ __ ] right he did all right I
secretly believed he was a stripper
because he had seen some of the photos
though he evidently had special showings
for like lemons only shelling lady and
it may have been I could lay around I
think maybe they might have been some
special showings for men too yeah
alright because why it was not happy
with him in the end of his life and he
wouldn't she wouldn't let him back in
the house and some have theorized that
he may have sold his services to some
men that's possible I don't know
probably other women too just selling it
all yeah well he was a [ __ ] fine
specimen for his day even today he would
have been impressive to see walking down
that's a big [ __ ] dude yeah but he
would tear his suit off you know I mean
like that and the clicking and the crowd
would just go [ __ ] wild and if I'm
gonna get up there and [ __ ] best
everything that that dude could do I'm
pumped that [ __ ] strong man out and
then and then he would plug his show
from dude stage pretty ballsy yeah he
strongman it's like thanks a lot
yeah fired get up there and [ __ ] cut
the [ __ ] out of the guy
cut the [ __ ] out of Steel his shelves
that was he had up the game yeah if you
were in his position you had all these
second and third rate strongmen running
around that weren't as strong as you
it's just about you'd be your natural
right really to just go out there and go
these guys are all weak compared to me
you can see see I can do this I can do
this I can do that and which is forcing
them but up the game yeah he was making
everybody better making everybody
[ __ ] you have to lift you have to
really lift you know cuz some a strong
minutes a lot of it was kind of tricks
some of it yeah like not all of it and
like I said we've been into that a
little bit we didn't really talk about
strongmen a lot on our circus sideshow
thing but because I figured we'd
probably be doing one of these shows
later on but a lot of the [ __ ] in there
was faked or at least it was not as cool
as it looked so I do think a lot of the
strongmen you know were you know the
weights were not they weren't as heavy
as you thought they were that heavier
they like would switch out of the
barbell with the big spheres on the end
of it some of them were solid and some
were Hollow yeah yeah I mean so didn't
weigh anywhere as much as it was nowhere
near as much it might save 200 pounds on
it yeah but it actually only weighed a
hundred yeah that kind of stuff which is
still heavy but not too light but yes so
yes so like you said with this first
competition which was won by a guy named
William Murray and the trophy that they
got is still as far as I know the same
trophy that they give to mr. Olympia now
it
yes and uh it's a sculpture of Sandow
and they had a gold one a silver one and
a bronze one I think the one they do for
mr. Olympia is the bronze one now right
but I think it would like it at the
first competition he had a gold silver
and bronze just like in the Olympics and
as far as I know like I said I don't
have this exact same sculpture but it's
you know I think it is they don't like
it it's still like you know the one of
the they started doing that in the 70s I
think for the mr. Olympia that they Joey
started making yeah Joey it was like his
idea to like make the the trophy look
like that the same one it looks similar
at least yeah cuz the one the one that
they were handing out for the Olympia it
looks like something from the 1800's the
style
yeah cuz it was a sculpture that
somebody made of him and Russ like a
little bitty sculpture yeah like yeah
it's kind of sand out looking like David
kind of like the Romans - yeah you know
I mean the David daughter kind of looks
like that but he's holding that Tam the
barbed thing about yeah yeah big old bar
bill now the first to that so that would
happen in England then they had the
first one that was in the United States
was actually a very end of 1903 in the
early nineteen oh four it was like a
couple of days and that was at Madison
Square Garden now this was like I don't
know if Santa had anything to do with
this one but this one was a guy named
Bernard McFadden he was he's known as
the father of physical culture and he
was what he started publishing like
bodybuilding magazines like health and
strength and stuff like that so that was
the first one in the United States the
guy that won that one was named Alger
allure and he was called the most
perfectly developed man in the world
he won $1,000 which back then that was a
[ __ ] ton of money I looked it up cuz I
was like how much is that nowadays
$29,000 so not bad you know for back
then so they also so Thomas Edison also
did a like made a film of this guy's
like posing routine so I don't know so I
got to see if I can find that and maybe
I can like put it in this I'm sure like
I don't know if it's survived or not but
uh yeah Edison had made some films of
Sandow as well yeah you had talked about
and he had done those
a couple of years before that so the two
the films of Sandow and the films of
ultra lore were like the first official
like bodybuilding films like ever made
yeah you know so you had what year is
this now this is 1904 1904 yes yeah and
like I said the first one the first
bodybuilding competition that sanded it
but that was nineteen yeah because I
remember the Santa was starting to start
to work out starting to get big he was
on that path in the in the 1890s yeah so
by the time that you know 1904 rolling
right he was already big yeah because I
mean the the whole circus strongman
thing that started like mid 19th century
yeah and then he started coming about
like in 1880 1890 somewhere around there
like he started like coming to the fore
and like doing all that kind of stuff
like the body pulling stuff so you know
there were a lot of like other early
ones and like it's you know some people
started like publishing magazines and
[ __ ] like that like in the 30s and 40s
it's funny because I remember they said
one of the earliest bodybuilders was
Francis X Bushman who was actually quite
a famous silent film actor and he was
actually had either trained understand
our was like a big fan of his and he was
a bodybuilder and he also worked as a
sculptors model then he went on and did
silent films later on I was like hey I
heard of that guy so it kind of went on
until in the 50s and 60s it started
getting like a lot more popular because
like a lot of the magazines started
going a little bit more like try you
know not mainstream exactly but starting
to get more popular you get you got like
more like strength competitions
gymnastics competitions that kind of
stuff there was more focus on you know
weight training like how to do it
properly there was more focus on
nutrition like proper nutrition learning
how like bulking and cutting um that
kind of came about in the 50s and 60s I
got her I got a mention though 30s and
40s you already started to see some
fantastic physiques though yeah and a
some people have said there must have
been anabolics involved because you
looked at the dudes they had classic
physique you know which is
they kind of looked like no no hood
ornaments yeah kind of big upper body's
good six-pack kind of normal it's
looking legs you know look like a
stereotypical superhero looks like like
Superman like a cigarette
I don't believe Hannah bollocks was
involved they knew about testosterone
they were in by time the 40s had come
around they kind of had some of the
theoretical stuff though they kind of
had knowledge of anabolics but they were
it wasn't being produced this was you
know they didn't really have the
technology you could extract
testosterone from a bunch of dog nuts or
bull nuts or whatever old bull nuts yeah
about those the other but if you just
injected that into your into your
bloodstream it would turn into something
else real quickly the half the half-life
was very short of something like that
yeah
it wouldn't be in your bloodstream long
enough to help you at all
get be get big as performance-enhancing
it's not until the [ __ ] 50s that they
had all the chemicals in the chemistry
available to make what you need to be
called a steroid all right so I'm just
trying to shoot down some of the stuff I
was listening to guys that did all the
[ __ ] research you know what I mean
call them [ __ ] on people saying now
these dudes in the 30s in the force they
must have had some kind of a
testosterone or performance and had no
they're natural they knew about that
stuff but it wasn't being produced and
the technology wasn't reliable and even
if they got their hands on it it
would've been super expensive and real
unreliable it wasn't until the damn 50s
late 50s in the 60s and even then it was
expensive but they had it but it was
super expensive even in the 50s it
wasn't widespread wasn't widespread it
wasn't where it was in the 50s and in
the 60s it wasn't to the point to where
a gym rat could go to a gym and get his
hands on a reliable source of anabolic
steroids that he could afford it wasn't
there yeah it wasn't it really was until
the 70s No
I think that's when when it became a
little bit more late 60s early 70s
that's probably when they could get
their hands on it for a reasonable but
that sounds about right because it just
seemed like Daddy would they'll Golden
Age of bodybuilding and that's when they
all appeared yeah okay and it had a lot
to do with California and Joe Weider
down to Joe's at Gold's Gym because
right across the border inside Mexico
was a [ __ ] laboratory that was making
high quality anabolic steroids yeah it
wasn't even it wasn't illegal tortoise
hmm it was new legal it was yeah and
that's where all that came from there's
a lot I mean still there's still like a
lot of restrictions on it nowadays even
though some of the bodybuilding
associations don't explicitly forbid it
in competition some competitions do
though well if you're gonna go to the
Olympia man is required yeah
they just automatically assume well you
gotta be on roids to be in this
competition well didn't they start
didn't they start drug testing them no
in the 90s I know maybe for a year or
two I don't or maybe no maybe it was
2000 I can't run I said oh no they were
talking about it on the documentary but
I don't know if thank goodness too long
because the Olympia is the [ __ ]
steroid competition it's a competition
to see well they were talking about how
and I guess like I said the documentary
I saw was five years old but they were
talking about how at that time what was
then the current time how everything was
more going toward like mass monsters
like people just wanted to get bigger
and bigger bear and they turned to get
like really freakish looking rather than
and some of the people were like kind of
lamenting like oh we're getting away
from like the symmetry and the
aesthetics and everything which
bodybuilding was originally supposed to
be about and now everybody just wants to
look like this big roided-out monster
yeah
but I feel like in the last few years
it's kind of going back and go back to
classic physique classic yeah and and I
think even a couple years ago they even
started they even had that subcategory
now they have like classic physique and
you have like all different you know
ones but yeah so like you said you
mentioned Joe Weider Joe and Ben wieder
the brothers they actually started the
International Federation of bodybuilders
in 1946 and so right around this time
like I said right before the dawn of the
50s all these new like bodybuilding you
know Federation's and associations like
sprang up and they all had their own
competitions so all these magazines
started me so it's kind of started to be
a thing where you know you could go
around and compete in all these
different you know contests if you were
into that type of thing now the mr.
Olympia competition which is now
considered if you win mr. Olympia you're
like the best bodybuilder in the world
that's like how its considered that
started in 1965 they did have prior to
that they did have mr. America mr. world
mr. universe mr. galaxy and all the
different [ __ ] mister cosmos no no no
no but yeah so mr. Olympia which fun
fact was apparently named after a beer
the two that they were drinking like
they were drinking at a bar and talking
about we should have like the best like
bodybuilding competition in the whole
world what should we call it he's like
and he's like looking at the beer bottle
he's like Olympia is like we can't call
it that's a beer Olympia like mounted
like a Mount Olympus they were gods
coming down yeah that's what he does
another guy said he's like we can name
it after a beer but our Superman story
they were supernatural what you're doing
it I think the natural versus modified
argument is well [ __ ] anyway because
bodybuilding itself
lifting weights isn't unnatural behavior
yeah we're talking about this on the
side traction and diets they're eating
and it's not something you'd be able to
get in nature if you were out there as a
hunter-gatherer that's why you didn't
see [ __ ] gigantic Indians or gigantic
[ __ ] Africans you know the minute
rise who the hell can eat like something
can't eat them some of those strongmen
like in the strongman competitions they
eat like 10,000 calories a day yeah and
they're like they have time to do that
yeah I've even been an according to
leave Leroy Colbert even before
steroids they were doing stuff around
the time steroids showed up when
steroids showed up they weren't
impressed with him because they they
didn't know it but they weren't taking
very high doses of it yeah
other guys were taking high doses of
vitamins and they were like inner Venus
vitamins they were like injecting
themselves with [ __ ] vitamin B
vitamin B's and B complex vitamins I
heard his injection some people said
they were eating it eating it but I
think it was injections and in that and
that time period according to the Leroy
the guys that were injecting vitamins
were getting bigger than the guys who
were taking steroids so the guys that
were taking steroids started up in their
doses and they got into like a [ __ ]
arms race between how many damn vitamins
you could inject into your bloodstream
or how many damn steroids it was like
two warring factions in the same gym and
where he was at California and
eventually it got to the point to where
the guys that were taking the steroids
were taking a dose that was about a
thousand times what they were greater
than what they were originally taking
that didn't have any results but over
time a steroids one out that actually
worked they they took him you know I
mean but the doses think we're talking
about much you needed a lot of now
that's the like the normal dose yeah but
they didn't know what the doses were
back then they were just taking the way
yeah it was like a new things a new like
they were almost like figuring it out
right but it makes me wonder how
effective were those vitamins they
claimed that injecting vitamins worked
and they didn't invent that because they
were injecting those vitamins into
cattle then the cattle were getting big
yeah but it's kind of like a lost art
now we just feed them corn well if you
didn't want they might still be doing it
I don't know it would if it works they
weren't they're probably just injecting
them with steroids cuz they're checked
on the chickens with steroids oh yeah
but how effective was injecting vitamin
B B vitamin it might have been pretty
good they thought it was yeah but who
knows if you can get it nowadays
yeah
double vitamin B I'm not really sure
they didn't invent that [ __ ] they got
that from him [ __ ] farmers that were
ejected that into cattle and it's funny
because when he said that it clicked in
my mind watching those old Looney tune
cartoons where somebody did inject Bugs
Bunny injected himself with vitamin B
and he got strong yes and maybe it was
like everybody knew everybody knew about
it back then enough it's like they put
in a Looney Tunes cartoon yeah it's like
a forgotten thing yeah steroids were
more effective so they yeah maybe it
like maybe other things came along that
suppliants that [ __ ] planted it or maybe
they found out later that it was harmful
or something no I just think it I just
think that I think it just got
supplanted yeah because it was more
probably more cost-efficient they got
bigger and it cost less and it was
faster yeah but how good was vitamin B
maybe it was pretty good
maybe it was 10% of what steroids were
yeah you know who knows in the thing
about vitamin B I don't know about
injectable vitamin B but I mean vitamin
B is not illegal no but it's just a
forgotten technology yeah you might be
able to go just start injecting you with
vitamins that they were putting in there
in the 40s and 50s and you might get
pretty big and and I've never heard any
gym rats talking about it other than
Leroy yeah and he was around mean he was
kind of one of the famous ones in the
50s right yeah yeah yeah and he now some
people have said Leo I didn't know what
he was talking about because the dudes
that were saying they were injecting
themselves with vitamin B were actually
injecting themselves with steroids yeah
that they were live it was quote-unquote
vitamin B they were just calling it my
virus right but evidently they were
doing it to cattle so that's something I
need to research yeah that's how
effective was it on cattle and how
effective was it on humans that's weird
yeah and would it [ __ ] up your liver
injecting it would bypass your liver
yeah I think they could yeah I'm not
sure
I don't know I'd have to look that up
well no injectable steroids are be
easier on your liver then than that oral
steroids yeah so well that makes sense
so that's why they do it yeah you can
eat oral steroids it just [ __ ] you up
yeah that's what Arnie took Oh oral
mostly yeah yeah yeah so we're a part of
you liver yeah and you kind of need your
heart her liver her tip he's still alive
though true hello you know a lot of them
lived they didn't know back then they
figured if it got you big and it got you
strong and it's good for you yeah you're
healthy they didn't know that was yeah
and like I said there's a lot of guys to
have taken just small amounts of it
they're fine it's just that you know
there's a such a thing as abuse you can
abuse any drug you could just do she
[ __ ] a lot of it you know yeah
because some of them some bodybuilders
do die kind of young yeah but I gotta be
honest when I was in high school there
were guys there were 16 years old that
were [ __ ] on gear yeah on the
football team taking [ __ ] steroids
it's why they were [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
huge [ __ ] huge at [ __ ] 17 the
[ __ ] you big yeah you know
bigger than a man
that's something out of [ __ ] predator
that was back in the 80s yeah you know
people forget everybody had to be all
[ __ ] [ __ ] yes yeah if schools I
was at you know every one of those
[ __ ] everyone pretty much every one
of those dev star football players was
[ __ ] on were on gear man they were on
steroids yeah
they were [ __ ] huge there was one of
my couldn't [ __ ] I know his name
[ __ ] was huge he must've been [ __ ]
sick something sick [ __ ] - probably
weighed like 250 pound it's like this
giant he got into a car wreck and he
couldn't remember my name when he saw me
after that car wreck his head was all
[ __ ] if he gained a bunch of weight
they all ended up fat now that I think
about it yeah they usually do because
they come off of all that [ __ ] yeah and
they're they're [ __ ] testosterone
[ __ ] count gets real [ __ ] low and
they gain a bunch of weight and they get
kind of
sergeant you got to stay on it if you're
that shitty thing about it is that you
you know if you're in competitions and
stuff it's gonna make you look good for
the competition and stuff but you can't
like once you get amped up to that point
you get that big you can't stop taking
it and you can't stop working you can
stop taking it a lot of them do they go
it's called going off cycle co-op cycle
just that you better
there's [ __ ] that you need to do to get
your normal testosterone going back to
normal post psychotherapy and then it's
probably best if you're older to go on
testosterone replacement therapy because
some of that [ __ ] [ __ ] up your
testosterone forever if you misuse it
basically at certain ages so you can be
on that forever and then you need to
work out you can't stop working out yeah
once you get to a certain level I'm not
talking about it you know just a casual
guy but you know I'm talking about you
get up to the pro level you can't stop
yeah yeah which you know and in a way
that's kind of bad cuz if it's like you
know bad for you and you can't stop
taking it but you know do you stop
taking it you get fat no you can't stop
working out yeah you can stop taking it
you you have to a lot of times but
there's got to be maintenance levels of
stuff every one of them that's [ __ ]
huge like that you know like many many
pounds over there genetic potential if
you actually analyze what they're doing
they're kind of like drug addicts yeah
cuz they come off steroids but then they
go on other things and they're on TRT
and then it got always constantly take
something it kind of takes something
because we're trying to maintain this
all this muscle that's not supposed to
be there yeah you know they stopped
taking that [ __ ] then the the muscle
goes away and then they end up at their
what their genetic potential was they
get smaller yeah they don't necessarily
get fat but some of these guys are
addicted to being bigger than they can
be like I said the roids ad ads that
last twenty pounds you know I mean when
the roids go away that last 20 pounds
goes back down there's still got a lot
of muscle though yeah but if they
stopped working out and they stopped
everything they'll they'll get real fat
because that'll just be or now or at
least when they're young yeah what I saw
if a dude maybe he maybe he's 50 and he
worked out his whole life you know I
mean he's got a lot of condition
and maybe he didn't spend a lot of time
beyond his genetic potential with that
extra 20 pounds on there you know I mean
maybe he lost that a long time ago and
was maintained it there because there
are some of these pros that haven't
competed for a long long time they're in
their 60s and 70s they look great yeah
but there's they work out you stay still
work out and I don't know I mean do they
take little are they on testosterone
replacement therapy probably are they
taking like occasional light cycles of
steroids to kinda like rejuvenate
themselves even if it's a lot of muscle
mass you know I mean that for an old man
you know I mean so maybe you might need
a little bit of that to kind of freshen
things up again every few years you know
I don't know because a lot of times they
won't take they want to say they just do
things as they need it yeah you know I'm
kind of wondering though like some of
the guys that I saw in the documentary
that were you know competing in mr.
Olympia like in 2013 2014 and as I said
at that time period it seemed like
everything was just going bigger bigger
bigger and like the guy that won that
year because he was like eight times in
a row or something like that he was
almost 300 pounds and they were saying
how that was like unprecedented how this
they just kept getting bigger and bigger
and bigger and heavier and heavier and
they were kind of like having a
discussion over whether it's like is it
really fair for a dude that weighs it's
like 300 pounds of muscle to be
competing against somebody that's like
works out but it's like aesthetically
pleasing and muscular and stuff but only
weighs like 180 pounds right he's like
maybe like in boxing or in other sports
they should have like weight classes
well I think they kind of do that now
yeah that was they weren't in the tower
of this documentary right amounts maybe
they've done it subsea also have like
natural they do an actual body built but
those guys kind of look [ __ ] weird as
[ __ ] and and because they got to be
really lean so they starve themselves
down I don't think the natural
competition looks right but what looks
better than the natural to me would be
what they call men's fitness yeah which
is weird because they're they're allowed
to have these big-ass [ __ ] shorts
that go down to their knees yeah Borja
and they all got those [ __ ] same
shorts on it looks [ __ ]
stupid [ __ ] cuz yeah why did they do
that they don't work their legs out at
all I know but it's like still wear some
[ __ ] normal shorts yeah yeah but
they're just they're young guys and
they're dumb there's something kind of
betta like about all wanting to [ __ ]
wear the same shorts if you ask me you
know I mean it's just they're gonna be
followers and look like everybody else
and a lot of to me a lot of the Men's
Fitness guys they look they look exactly
the same
yeah but so did a lot of female models
but go ahead there's this get let's go
on them on them yeah so in the 1950s
like I said um you know the bodybuilding
got like a larger you know like a
mainstream kind of more footprint I
guess just because of TV and like they
had people like you know Jack LaLanne
you had a Steve Reeves and he was in
like the Hercules movies debriefs was
[ __ ] him amazing he was a very large
time he was just [ __ ] at me I've seen
a bunch of his Hercules movies because
they did a bunch of em on MST and also
uh Mickey Hargitay who also played
Hercules in one movie that was on MST
and who also was married to Jayne
Mansfield for two and they were in the
Hercules movie together as far as I can
remember it can't remember what the name
of the [ __ ] Hercules movie was I saw
it on Mystery Science Theater but yeah
Mickey Hargitay it was actually quite
large
Steve Reeves Khanna when you see him I
kind of want to say he was on steroids
but the man was kind of before steroids
are real common he must have just
[ __ ] I don't know mr. had just
[ __ ] superior genetics yeah I do feel
like some people I mean everybody can
look good but some people are just gonna
look that that dude was one in a million
for a natural you know cuz I mean they
even talked about like you know when
they were talking about mr. Olympia
they're talking about like people like
Sergio Oliver and people like that who
one thing that they said about him when
he first came into like the [ __ ] mr.
Olympia competition was that he looked
like he had like the best genetics of
anybody that they had ever seen because
he he was not only like really really
big and really symmetrical but he had
like a really small waist and it was
like natural yeah kagome taper
yeah yeah yeah and like you don't see
that a lot I guess
it's
genetic yeah and if you don't have it
that you're gonna need [ __ ] some kind
of chemical assistance to get that and
the thing about it too is that a lot of
bodybuilding competitions and maybe a
lot of people don't know this but that
when they like before they compete they
pretty much they don't drink any water
right or no salt no nothing like because
they don't want any water retention they
don't want anything like that they put
like they inject stuff into their
muscles like called fluffing to like
make them look a little bit bigger they
before they go out on stage they like
kind of like lift weights and like pull
towels and stuff like that to like get
to puff them that's all love and
everything like that they have like all
these [ __ ] tricks and you know
obviously oiling and tanning and all
that other kind of stuff to like make
everything look better but uh there was
this one guy and I said [ __ ] I can't
like remember his name I don't have a
picture of him but um he was talking
about he was on this documentary he was
talking about how he wanted to be like
the butt guy like he wanted have like
the best butt and like all the [ __ ]
because this is like the level that
we're at so it's about looks well the
weird thing well the weird thing about
it there was he was like going on and on
about that I'm like alright let's see
this this vaunted but that you're
talking about and he had the [ __ ]
weirdest Oh Macedo where has to be one
of those kind of monkey butts it doesn't
have any fat on it at all I've seen that
I've seen that what you're talking about
just looks kind of like flat a bunch of
lines yeah yeah yeah yeah and I was like
that's what you wanted yeah some of us
stop you if you ask me some of this
bodybuilder [ __ ] it goes too far yeah
end up with some dude it looks like a
damn Anatomy poster you know there's an
attic posters with the [ __ ] scan gone
you end up looking like that trying to
get all these little striations and
having 0% body fat it's just you're
gonna die yeah and it doesn't look good
no one's supposed to have zero position
yeah yeah it doesn't work no it does I
don't think I don't find it I don't I
don't it doesn't it doesn't look good
well that's what I mean and that's what
I was like what it is because I just I
was working on something else and I was
like watching the watching the
documentary on over here and he kept
going on and on about how he was gonna
be the but guide everything I'm like so
what does the butt look like so I look
at the butt and I'm just like oh
yeah I didn't need to say that it didn't
even look like a good nothing like a
little squishable bud or nothing like
that it was just like this really weird
Foley yeah flat yeah
thanks really you know market ah it's
hard to top like Steve reaps you talk
about Steve reason yeah just that looks
more like a person yeah you know I mean
he looks like a big buck baby looks like
Hercules like I said is the vice you are
Superman yeah and you know what what do
you know how can you improve on that
it's called aesthetics you can't improve
on that that's just that's the way now
there's always gonna be individual
variations another man might be just as
excellent but have a slightly different
appearance but it might compete with
that yeah you know I mean but some of
the [ __ ] that you were talking about
it's too extreme yeah like I said what
is not some of the newer guys or some of
the guys that were competing in Olympia
like in the you know the main category
um you know in like you know five or six
years ago they just looked freakish to
me and they look like just big ogre
Tantalus like all these [ __ ] veins
it's like this freaky freaky like I'm
not in a matte deal there's only one
masked monster that looks good to me
that's Kai green yeah he's a black guy
has a big long ponytail it goes down he
looks very good for a mass monster but
the other ones they cut up yes
it's very it doesn't it suits him but it
doesn't suit a lot of the other yes
Jimmy it just looks like unsettling it's
not aesthetic and it's not aesthetic and
I'm not the only one saying that there's
a lot of bodybuilders they're gonna say
that the masked monster yes some people
knows what they proved what they wanted
to prove yeah how big can you [ __ ]
get they proved it though you can get as
big as a car okay with the right help
you can get as big as a car that's
[ __ ] over with they need to go back
to want to look like a damn [ __ ] hood
ornament I do feel like I'm back in that
droid cos like I said at the very end of
this documentary they were talking about
you know they were talking to some of
the guys that won mr. Olympia and they
were very very large like I said they're
almost 300 pounds and they did like talk
to a lot of people a lot of
bodybuilders a lot of people in the
scene and stuff like that they were like
I really wish we could get back to you
know where it was more about symmetry or
aesthetic like that instead of just
trying to get as big as possible and
just have these like bizarre like
looking freaks of nature that don't look
like any reasonable person could get to
that standard because it almost seems
like and we were talking about this on
the sidetrack show it's almost kind of
like you know
people that get like plastic surgery
like a little bit like getting a nip and
tuck here and there getting a boob job
getting somewhere that looks good but
then some people just take it to these
ridiculous extremes which that's their
prerogative when I'm giving like the
lion woman yeah like you can do whatever
you want with your body I'm not like you
know I'm not judging I'm just saying
that there comes a point where it just
doesn't look diminishing returns yeah it
just doesn't look good anymore I don't
think I mean you know what I mean so I I
do kind of feel like the dudes that just
feel like like the butt guy and the guys
that you know want to be 300 pounds and
like just have muscles on top of muscles
and just look like the [ __ ] Michelin
Man or whatever I'm just like I I feel
like there might be something going on
there like something lacking like what
was like it's like manorexia it's
manorexia but what was funny like back
in the 80s growing up seeing Arnold you
know and I never would you know a Franco
Columbu man he looked [ __ ] great
llevas armless friend yeah he was in
public I met he was also in Kona yet he
was like the little Scout that [ __ ]
scouted out before the [ __ ] attack
happened in the bag Franco [ __ ]
Franco was art an owner arnold's [ __ ]
friend who died just about a year back
drought [ __ ] sad
holy [ __ ] yeah he was out swimming and
drowned in a pool or in a you know shoot
the ocean oh yeah he had a heart attack
while swimming oh yeah but you know
these guys are getting up there in age
ya know so that some people said well
add that steroids he lived a [ __ ]
high quality life Franco and he was a
great guy
[ __ ] Arne called him a little what he
called him a little mutant monkey man
he said he was subhuman okay subhuman
that was his best buddy I just feel like
thanks yeah Frank was like uh-huh what
he said in front of franca he was like
subhuman like a little monkey man he can
lift he could lift a whole refrigerator
you know just because he was talking
about him during that strongman copy
yeah that Franco he's like five foot
four or five four five she's about Lee
Priest sighs but he's like a rule he
looked good but he was [ __ ] extremely
[ __ ] strong much stronger than he
should have been for his size he
evidently could lift more than Arnold
because arresting we had a smaller
skeleton with a bunch of [ __ ] muscle
packed on it so yeah a little more
leverage a little more leverage and you
don't have to move away this far true
yeah
long bones you know I mean require a lot
of [ __ ] muscle and you know to move a
heavy weight but Arnold was talking
about you know that he was [ __ ]
stronger than he should have been and he
said he was like he was subhuman like a
monkey like a gorilla you know that's me
bet they're buddies you know they're
[ __ ] Arnold [ __ ] okay Leroy I tell
you on [ __ ] on Leroy Colbert is
[ __ ] YouTube channel he's got [ __ ]
thousands of videos I sit there and
listen to that [ __ ] old man just so I
could talk to you like for [ __ ] days
and days and days he'll tell you stories
about [ __ ] Arnold and he had
recordings of him talking to Arnold back
in the 80s he had recordings of it you
know and Arnold tell him to [ __ ] shut
up he talks too much and [ __ ] she
wouldn't stop running his mouth and when
you think of Arnold Schwarzenegger you
think kind of like a serious guy you
know but no I [ __ ] was a clown
and he was kind of stuck up and he likes
to [ __ ] with people a lot I believe that
he liked to [ __ ] with people a lot and
he loved to [ __ ] all right I believe
that he loved to [ __ ] [ __ ] people
would ask him you know how did you get
so big and he would go this is what you
do you take a little bit of dishwater
and you put it inside your [ __ ] tree
drink a little bit of dishwater every
[ __ ] day and what it is is he
cuz he's not gonna tell people well you
know I got this big because of roids and
lifted [ __ ] question he's gonna give
you a stupid answer and people would
take this for entertaining but yeah
probably get people asking the same [ __ ]
all the time
ya gotta like mix it up to entertain
yeah he would he would [ __ ] sex a
crazy [ __ ] tells crazy stories and would
[ __ ] lie basically but it was not
really lying maliciously but make [ __ ]
up at least you were telling rat poison
nah he'd give you [ __ ] bum bum
information and bum advice just to see
if you'd do it yet I mean because you're
get by asking him yeah I see that I I
didn't see you like getting so sick of
people asking the same [ __ ] all the time
that you just like start telling them
Hornet came out with this damn dot this
video video it's this movie and it's
selling this diet called the game
changer and it's about vegetarianism
okay and how vegetarianism is a superior
diet and all the gladiators in Rome with
vegetarians and [ __ ] you know [ __ ]
elephants or vegetarians and [ __ ]
Lions of vegetarians or whatever you
because they're vegetarian you get
[ __ ] big you know it's all [ __ ]
[ __ ]
Arnold didn't get big from vegetarianism
[ __ ] Arnold sat around eating [ __ ]
me taking lots of steroids yeah lots of
like a protein very high protein done I
mean I know that there are some
bodybuilders who are vegetarians and me
there's a lot of fake the dryer I'm not
yeah I'm not user bodybuilders I'm not
sure if they actually are no I'm just
saying no they're saying it's hard to
say I'm not while I'm not in their
kitchen I'm not watching they're just
saying that mostly if they're vegetarian
vegetarian can can get protein products
from cream and cheese and they can eat
whey protein that's that's okay you
could do that I guess you could do that
but purely vegetarian you know I mean
some people would
like vegan you can't gain any muscle on
that on believe that beauty eat like a
lot of nuts and a lot of stuff like that
but then once you do that to get the
protein you need you have to get you
have to take in lots and lots of
calories you can't eat eggs and all the
rise and stuff it just it really you're
I'm not saying it can't be done I'm just
saying it's really difficult right and
gladiators were not vegetarians
gladiators were [ __ ] slaves okay they
fed him whatever they had on hand they
probably said because they were gonna
kill a lot of them [ __ ] you know
within the next few weeks
most gladiators were cannon fodder
gladiators they [ __ ] didn't live long
the pro famous gladiators which they
stayed around for a long time because
their owners didn't want them killed in
the ring all right and they had huge fan
bases yeah so usually they fought to a
defeat and then they were allowed to go
back and heal up you know I mean and so
I'm back up those particular celebrity
gladiators actually had a good survival
rate and they were making [ __ ] tons of
money and they ate the finest of [ __ ]
food that Rome had had to offer because
their owners were making a [ __ ] ton of
money off of them
yeah because another thing that they
would do with those famous gladiators is
pimp them out they pip him out to [ __ ]
wealthy women yeah alright cuz it was
huge [ __ ] there were huge celebrities
and it was like a big thrill to four
noble women to go screw some gladiator
cuz he was like a bad boy gladiator D
there where they were criminals
okay criminals and captured soldiers you
know from some enemy barbarian armies
and they kind of had that bad-boy
mystique and they were famous yeah so
you know they made money off them in all
these different ways well those guys
were not vegetarians no they fed they
ate well so a lot of the premises in
that video are not true if you're a
vegetarian and you want to be a
bodybuilder we're taught my bodybuilder
level performance you know vegetarian
it'd be difficult it'd be so much better
want to just become
if you're worried about the damn little
fluffy fuzzy animals and [ __ ] which I
can understand that become a pescetarian
yet because fish is actually one of the
hello Birds man yeah
highly concentrated low calorie protein
very free of fat fish shrimp crab
shellfish all that [ __ ] can build a
fantastic physique that's just pure
unadulterated high concentrated protein
low calorie you know that's the way to
go
yeah and eating a shrimp like eating a
robot doesn't matter they're mindless
like although it's a sea bug eat that
even though they're delicious I'll
[ __ ] do it yeah I can eat my own
weight yeah cuz you know God we got a
Sophie you know she's a vegan
and she tried she's working out she's
trying to get bigger and bigger you know
it's more stronger and I'm just telling
her said man that's not really the way
to go you need to get some mittens so
she's eating P protein you know the
green paper okay which that's better
than no protein at all but I don't think
it's as concentrated as whey protein in
terms of like I said you I feel like
maybe you would probably have to eat a
lot of nuts and things imagine your
calories but yeah nuts well depending on
what kind of nuts you eat like uh some
nuts like peanuts and cashews and stuff
like that are very fatty
you tried to eat as little calories as
possible but as many [ __ ] building
blocks as possible so in other words
you're trying to almost kind of be in a
slightly caloric deficit to get ripped
but you have to have enough [ __ ]
muscle or enough protein to build muscle
yeah so it has to be very high protein
low fat all right very low calorie so if
fish that's the yes
they had a bodybuilder but they goes
back in the 70s who is a pescetarian and
that dude was [ __ ] huge and he was
[ __ ] walking around smelling
like Aquaman [ __ ] get me Creature from
the Black Gate [ __ ] just [ __ ] coming
out of the pores and [ __ ] like king of
the sea ain't [ __ ] cuz you eat nothing
but [ __ ] fish you're gonna smell like
fish
they just do problem it comes out of
your pores although I have to say that
if somebody came along and told me that
I can only one type of meat for the rest
of my life shrim probably be fish not
shrimp yeah I can eat shrimp or fish or
shrimp rush it out it's like seafood
yeah like I mean I would miss like
turkey and beef and chicken and stuff
but if somebody told me that was I can
only do one type of meat it would well
if they told me only one kind of meat
and it was all about flavor it would be
beef but if I factored in health it
would be shrimp yeah if I could have all
the shrimp I want it yeah I would just
be sure this [ __ ] man whenever we just
wouldn't whenever we would go to like
the Chinese all-you-can-eat buffet I
would always the best days to go because
they always have like shrimp and mussels
and stuff like that not always get like
a bunch of that but the best you know
the best days when we were there was the
days when they had a whole bunch of fish
stuff yeah hold our seafood they had
like little squid and eating all the
shrimp you can and then I would go
around looking for every single fish
dish that they have a little bit we
should probably take a break oh good ink
yeah cuz we've already gone an hour and
20 minutes or 15 minutes something like
that
so when we come back we're gonna talk
about the Golden Age of bodybuilding
yeah that's my kind of stuff pumping
iron and all that kinds a good time in
history growing up seeing these guys go
wow I'm gonna look like that one day no
never happened I know I'm just I'm doing
history for vision ISM right so we're
gonna take a break I moved back in just
a couple minutes okay so remember how I
told you that Beijing would bring his
little babies out overnight
here's her handiwork from last night
okay there's the first little fox a
little bit
then here's the second set and there's
Pookie like what the hell yeah chalo
monster - they might be some in the
guest room - I haven't looked
what's up Pookie did you see that
Beijing left all the babies maybe it's
someone - okay hi Pookie what are you
doing yeah you're just chillin on your
back with your little tail wagging yeah
you're all funky she's like why are you
telling me this is like the most natural
thing the problem yeah what do you have
to say a muppet what do you think about
that Pookie
not much okay look at these a little bit
oh my goodness oh my goodness
yeah okay you love true crime I love
true crime and I've spent the last three
years compiling a series of the most
intriguing unsolved murders of the 20th
century it's called the faceless villain
and volume 3 is available now featuring
such fascinating cases as the Caddy
murders the carry babies case the Frog
Boys the al-qasr murders and the
inokashira park dismemberment incident
the faithless villain volume three is an
involving exploration of unsolved slang
spanning the years from 1980 to 1999
pick up your copy and print or eBook
formats on Amazon or download the
audiobook version from audible.com and
get ready for a chilling journey through
modern crime history
all right we're back talking about the
history of bodybuilding yeah we never
did tell him what happened to Eugen
Sandow what happened to him
guy well that's what he sure right there
he died that's enough most people he was
he ran his car off into the ditch it was
old heavy ass car that he had and he got
got underneath one of the corner of the
car wheels and lifted the car up out of
the ditch a part of the car at a ditch
and then drove off and seemingly died
later possibly a brain aneurysm but he
was over when he did I'm left in the car
I've lived in the car that's what they
did I remember you telling me that yeah
the car his wife wouldn't let him back
in the house because of all the
shenanigans he did some kind of
shenanigans that he did some kind of
shenanigans and they wouldn't tell the
press so it's kind of been surmised that
he maybe was doing something bad either
with men or women probably involved
money and or both at the same time sure
yeah she wouldn't talk about it so it's
been surmised that it was gay stuff you
yeah gay stuff so they decided they
didn't want to talk about it back in the
50s that's like--that's however it
wasn't 50s oh yeah that was more like
30s 30s something like that he was older
but I think the break-up happened you
know like a decade before that right so
they have when he was younger he got
kind of estranged from his wife but it's
never really been solved what the
problem was everyone's just like assumed
they'd assumingly because it was the
1930s and yeah that's what you would
think because yeah [ __ ] wasn't okay back
then for whatever right okay cuz they
some people have survived well if it was
a woman she would have said right you
know what I mean or tolerated it because
I think that was kind of like okay back
in those days too I mean I don't know if
it was okay but it's kind of like
nothing that wasn't a big deal do you
know I mean
they couldn't really do anything about
it yeah but they couldn't anything about
it but I also I think it was Connolly
there's a lot of cultures where it's
kind of expected yeah yeah I mean like
Brazil is cuz it's kind of like oh well
yeah they just do that men do that
that's what dudes do as amended they
just stick their dick in anything yeah
the women by that time they don't care
other way they're like at least it's not
me
apple pies at least it's not me yeah nah
I was in Brazil back in the 80s you know
I was kid but like the culture there it
was just like older guys you know in
their 50s and [ __ ] you know they all had
mistresses and the wife was thankful my
hair exactly least he's not in my house
making a mess ya know it's like at least
I don't have to have sex with yeah
that's also a plus right you gotta look
at it realistically yes at least I don't
have to that's usually out on her yeah
yeah that's why you know all these
people get upset all those men is
usually in most cultures that do that
like that was your attitude most
cultures that do that the women don't
give a [ __ ] they're thankful thankful
yeah like I said at least he's not
hanging around looking you know being a
pain in my head yeah they get to shop
all day yeah I don't enjoy shopping as a
leisure and women did back in the 80s I
mean a lot a lot of people do I guess
but it's like I don't know anyway I go
get your nails done I guess because I
grew up poor so it's kind of like I
never got that shop get your nails done
go to spa get your hair cut if I can get
pampered in the [ __ ] [ __ ] go to cafes
all day and have waiters [ __ ] serve
them and [ __ ] that's just you know that
was Brazilian culture for the rich
people not saying I wouldn't like to
like get a massage or something one of
those days but yeah I don't really enjoy
likes all they did I don't really enjoy
like shopping as
Brazilian rich girls [ __ ] Justin rich
women just live pampered lives I like
just I like to just go and get what I
need and get the [ __ ] out of there yeah
so - so do rich women in the Middle East
they're just [ __ ] pampered man yeah
diamonds and jewelry and [ __ ] yeah
yes now hey you know I'm sure they'd all
don't live like that you know I mean
[ __ ] you know the real rich ones now
if I can live in Paradise and they might
have like a lot of wives - you know made
like sister wives
like Mormons yeah it's funny you know I
mean ever talked about the Middle East
all that they have all them wise they
have that here just nobody talks about
yeah it's good you just go to Mormon
territory they say it doesn't happen but
there's a lot of it's going on yeah it's
like just cuz you legally can't marry
well they're gonna say well that's
breakaway sex you know I says sex is
always break away that's just his
breakaway the Mormon the cults but
actually the they're reading it right
that's what that's well yeah that's what
it says in the crazy book that was on
the gold place from the aliens or
whatever the [ __ ] it was yeah you know
more you know the Book of Mormon and
Mormonism you know I had friends were
Mormons are [ __ ] great you know I
like you know they they do what they
want to do that's their culture
there were always kind of respectable
people from for the ones that I knew all
good-looking people because and I think
it's all that selective breeding that
they were doing but they were
good-looking
if you research the history I don't know
why I'm talking about Mormonism or damn
[ __ ] it was a copy as this is what
happened it was it was it was a copy of
Islam a lot of the a lot of the elements
in in Mormonism is lifted right out of
the Quran yeah yeah that's why I like
that somebody told us we should do a
whole show on Mormonism which I love
dude we probably should yeah yeah that's
a trip religion man you know I mean it's
very Gnostic and they had a lot of
rituals that really Outsiders didn't see
a lot of singing and dance and these
rituals bursting back in the 80s I don't
know if they're still doing it now but
like some of it leaked dressing up in
all these second special suits and
singing songs and men and women together
singing these songs and reenact and
stuff is you know it makes sense to to
Mormons it didn't it just looks like
Baptist Christian stuff it's just mixed
with like Scientology yeah yeah well
that always kind of struck me is like
it's like a weird cult II kind of thing
on top of it but in a lot of ways it was
just like a weird fundamentalist sect
there's a good cartoon about Mormonism
that the Mormons made explaining
Mormonism try to get more it's on you
say yeah about different different
stories about Jesus and Mary and if
you're good enough Mormon you're gonna
get your own planet you'll be God over
that planet and having my own planet
it's kind of like it's kind of like the
bridge yeah I mean the psychologists
call it the bridge yeah yeah it's like
an alien Moses names not Brigham Young
what was his name Joseph Smith
yeah he's the one that wrote all that I
believe yeah and just as Joseph Smith
had a [ __ ] wild imagination but can
getting talking to the angel Moroni and
looking ahead special [ __ ] glasses
that could read tablets that were given
to him and he's behind a curtain and
dictating them all out well that sounds
an awful lot like Mohammed talking to
the damn angel jibreel or Gabriel and
reciting the Quran that's very much
yeah same I think he was inspired by
that story or he ripped it off I mean
you could put that's the same thing yeah
I was inspired
yeah and then the whole thing about
having multiple wives and you know
that's that's that's his long well yeah
you probably read about that he's like
oh well like that I mean that much it
you have a wife but then you want a
girlfriend so you gotta have a
justification for that really that's in
that's in Christianity - yeah oh yeah
like a lot of the [ __ ] ya know
Charlamagne had a bunch of wives and it
was a part of the holy room he was the
[ __ ] emperor of the Holy Roman Empire
you know the this idea that Christians
only had one wife that's it that's a
that's a modern concept it is yeah oh do
you know throughout the Middle Ages and
everything there were certain Christians
they had many wives no because it
doesn't say in the new in the New
Testament that you can't do it
and yeah the Old Testaments
right it's now forbidden and hey you're
allowed to have a whole bunch of cows
we're allowed to have a whole bunch of
wives - yeah actually if you actually
turn interpret it really it's you
marriage is not between a man and a
woman a marriage is between a man a
woman a woman a woman a woman and
another woman your wife and all her
servants you know and who else your
brother his wife if he dies you get hurt
that one and all her services I don't
remember all the whole rules but it's
just a man and a whole bunch of [ __ ]
women that's what yeah
so don't let don't like I said you can
you can tell some man were at that [ __ ]
well man's gonna man what you if there's
another flaw because I've never a man
you wouldn't write it like that well I
don't know I'm not I'm not a man and I
don't know what your thought for us
because yeah well most women would not
write that because it's like one man is
more than enough
you don't really the innovation that's
what I mean don't care about that it's
like one man is enough of the pain it's
like you don't need back in those days
back in those days when women mostly
just had most of their time was
basically taken up providing for
children that's yeah you had to clean
[ __ ] is [ __ ] busy and in [ __ ]
fruit and do [ __ ] to make sure that all
the babies are being fed you don't have
time to worry about harems yeah that's
what I mean it's so we have a practical
concern you know we don't have time to
do it yeah I know they're building
empires and [ __ ] kicking people's
asses and get more territory there's no
time for that when you're a woman and
back in those days there's no birth
control you didn't just have one child
you probably yeah like by the time you
had that many it's like you were [ __ ]
tired man yeah you were too tired and
literally there Tona dude - get the [ __ ]
out of here yeah yeah just go conquer
some [ __ ] - yeah my face yeah let's get
back to the Golden Age it's like leaving
socks all over yeah yeah all right so we
okay so um we were talking about how
bodybuilding stars first started to come
in to like kind of more
mainstream acceptance I guess in the mid
1960s when they started coming out on TV
and [ __ ] like that
Muscle Beach had a lot yeah I was gonna
say Muscle Beach in Santa Monica now
prior to the mid 1960s there were like a
couple kind of famous gyms mostly in
California but until Gold's Gym opened
like as a chain like in the mid 1960s
there wasn't like you know a nationwide
kind of like chain of gyms but Gold's
Gym was the first one to do that kind of
thing
yeah now during this time in the comic
books that's when you started seeing in
the comic books like ads and the ads
were like showing a little wimpy guys
getting sand kicked in the face and if
you buy this [ __ ] things you you you
use dynamic tension to get huge and
Charles Atlas with his name was Charles
Atlas's dynamic tension method and which
was [ __ ] kind of well Moses it's
sold in a comic book you sold in a
column and then right next to that
they'd have something for the Black
Dragon Society [ __ ] count Dante [ __ ]
[ __ ] his magic [ __ ] and then dead
touches in there see monkeys monkeys
monkeys sea monkeys an x-ray guy
I bought sea monkeys it was brine shrimp
eggs well they're bright rapid and and I
was never patient enough to get up the
hatch you got to aerate the water and
[ __ ] use special salt and [ __ ] and it
tells you don't use tap water but you're
a little kid you're gonna use tap water
it's like where the [ __ ] else am I got
em all then you've put in the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] aeration thing for you to
blow air bubbles that eat out I mean and
then like [ __ ] two hours later you're
like where the [ __ ] monkeys take
squeaks you know my sea monkeys [ __ ]
look where is the family yeah this is
they showed up and they could shoot him
that little vial my dad goes and brine
shrimp eggs rises sea monkeys my dad my
dad laughing I mean he was getting live
brine shrimp feeding him to his damn
[ __ ] saltwater damn he had the damn
turkey fish or whatever you call it the
tiger fish Turkey it was this damn fish
the head it was orange with red stripes
on it and it had these [ __ ] poisonous
spines coming off of it as a saltwater
fish I don't like a lionfish lionfish
that's what it's gonna call it a tiger
fish a lionfish yeah a lionfish
oh they're beautiful yeah life is
seein enemies and a [ __ ] little
clownfish they would live in the sea
anenome and [ __ ] he goes you should have
told me you want to do is I got a homie
to my dad's boy you should have told me
you wanna do it I got a whole bucket of
them things I wanted a Mac when a yeah
well that that was when you learned that
advertising was [ __ ] I feel that's
how every kid learned yeah but that's
now Feeny you guys grew up during that
era yes there was a black dragon
fighting society we did the show autumn
that was count Dante and he was a [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ] dude tried to rob banks you
know [ __ ] was hanging out with the
organized crime he blew up a [ __ ] dojo
and did all kinds of [ __ ] it was down in
Chicago and somebody got stabbed with a
sword yeah and Charles Atlas got [ __ ]
sued for that damn advertisement with
the getting huge the dynamic tension
thing because it eluded that he got big
by using dynamic tension you can't get
big too big but using dynamic tension is
just push-ups push-ups and sit-ups and
like dips yeah here's always gonna be a
limit to how big you can get with it but
well I did what was his argument he's
like well he's like I didn't say I got
big like that I'm just saying maybe you
could get dead okay the way they can you
a whole bunch of other things as well
the way the ad was worded yeah does say
that he mad but I don't think it was I
think that might have been settled I'm
not sure I think if it might have been
settled out of court I don't remember
the details because I do kind of think
cuz even nowadays in advertising copy
you can get around certain laws by word
wording at the right particular we
didn't word it the right way
and yeah and it did evidently say that
he got big by using that his method yeah
all right what's that you could you
could say that as long as you didn't
imply that that was the only thing that
you did yeah Charles Atlas got big buy
[ __ ] lived in real big
[ __ ] heavy weights and probably
taking anabolic steroids I haven't seen
him the prize steroids he's pretty big
actually when I saw those ads when I was
a kid I didn't even think that was a
real thing is like some guys to say oh
I'm all natural you know during that era
wears kind of a gray area they might
have been natural for a long time but
then steer anabolic steroids became
available then it took them then - yeah
so it's hard to say you know I mean just
because you were natural at one time
that doesn't mean you were always
natural well the thing about it as
steroids weren't really technically
illegal until what 1990 something like
that no they were well you can still get
them I mean I think you can get them
with a prescription in Florida you can
but I'm gonna say you can't like buy
them just uh you know from what I've
heard that's going on here is that you
can go here in Florida they have these
little [ __ ] doctors offices where you
they call them male wellness the
treatment place then you get TRT like I
said it's all about the word it's all
about the wording you get and they do it
cookie cutter fashion they give you
[ __ ] testosterone replacement therapy
and then they give you some mother like
mood enhancement [ __ ] and then they give
you something I think might be anavar
you know which is [ __ ] steroids yeah
and it's just like a cookie cutter thing
and they'll [ __ ] give it to you
Florida's not uptight about it
it's state-by-state mood enhancement
this is my mood enhancer well no you
gotta have you gotta have something to
keep you from getting roid rage so they
have a drug yeah because you're gonna go
around like like it yeah mood
stabilizers it's like a moose table yeah
it's like stop being such a [ __ ]
[ __ ] back in the day and use that [ __ ]
they just take the steroids and [ __ ]
get me but yeah so now we're getting
into the silicon that Superman red Sun
yeah when a superior man shows up he was
[ __ ] roid not roid rage and yeah
fighting [ __ ] as soon as as soon as
they said like as soon as Lex Luthor
like Kali he's like these superior man
and of course he's fighting the [ __ ]
Russians Superman I'll hate you
you got bigger you got bigger tuned he
turned into like a gorilla I got so mad
he got bigger over there but then he
died what's wrong with you good cartoon
man that's go see read song yeah copy
this Superman they come in a Superman
you so now we're getting to the 1970s
the Golden Age of bodybuilding and this
is like I said when it started to go
mainstream because this 1977 was when
pumping iron came out yeah
good movie but I've never seen it I've
only seen it I've only seen a bunch of
clips from it I got to see it that's
like that's like that should be like
required watching this would be required
I should see that one but I haven't seen
it I've only seen clips from it it's
probably I think it's free on YouTube
for real is it like you should probably
look at it alright
I mean I've I saw it free somewhere but
either they're on to me but yeah it's
like look [ __ ] hilarious
yeah that's kind of where it's mostly
centered around you know the just the
competition it's like Arnold
Schwarzenegger it's Lou Ferrigno and
like their kind of rivalry and then
there's like some others Franco Columbu
is on there and some other people so
it's kind of like just like a
documentary about like the lead-up to
that competition and like them like [ __ ]
talking each other and like training and
all this other kind of [ __ ] and then
there's like a bunch of like behind the
scenes stuff you know not just [ __ ]
talking but also like Arnold like
smoking pot and doing yeah it was
supposed to be it's actually kind of
like the first attempt at like reality
TV except it's a movie yeah and it's not
a hundred percent legit evidently they
they got Arnold to be a dick is you know
more often to make well make the movie
more entertain more deta yeah just like
they do on talk shows and yeah
reality TV nowadays yeah they just make
everyone mad gotta see it acting like
[ __ ] because everybody wants to see
people acting like [ __ ] are like
acting
nobody was why I thought if I was a
[ __ ] total dick and went [ __ ]
crazy all the time on this show we'd
have [ __ ] millions of subscribers I'd
be picking fights with other channels
and [ __ ]
maybe I'll get all kinds of [ __ ]
subscribers oh no whoa well no because
if that's not entirely true because a
lot of this because I don't yeah I don't
like that kind of [ __ ] so I don't watch
it but but a lot of the shows that I
like that are not like that um I have
like a hundred thousand yeah subscribers
[ __ ] like that so it's not necessary it
may not work anymore but back in the day
if you picked a fight with another
channel you can get a lot of subscribers
yeah and I do felt I do feel like there
was a time when like the douchier you
were like the more subscribers because
everyone just wanted to like hate watch
I hate watch is still a click though
it's real watch it they're still paying
you trail well they might not be paying
you but yeah yeah depends on if it's
monetized or not yeah I don't know I
just I'm not that kind of person it's
like I don't enjoy that so I feel like
that would stress me out even more like
yeah producing something of that nature
because it because it wouldn't be like
what I'm really like right you know what
I mean could be fake yeah exactly so um
so at this stage like when pumping iron
came out and it was like a really big
success
um Arnold Schwarzenegger hadn't been any
movies at this time although Lou
Ferrigno had kind of this was right
around the time that he was in the Hulk
right or it was like a little bit after
that before yeah because when was the
Hulk that was like 70s no pumping iron
was 78 yes so maybe it was like shortly
after this came out so this so this was
kind of like a cultural a big cultural
thing because it really kind of
introduces particularly these two actors
and then you had the IFBB which you know
Joe Weider had started and they kind of
took over is like being like the main
you know competitive bodybuilding like
outfit you know what I mean and like the
other one's kind of like fell behind
though they did have another one called
the national physique committee and they
kind of like got to be a big deal as
well and they're kind of they do like
the amateur version I guess of the IFB
because I have maybe I guess they do mr.
Olympia and then this other one like
does the amateur division so let's talk
a little bit about because the 70s were
right around the time when steroid use
started to become more widespread and in
the 70s it seemed like bodybuilders
talked a lot more openly about it
because like I said there wasn't a
stigma about it um you know it was
essentially as far as I know it was
pretty much legal everywhere there isn't
there isn't a stigma in most of the
world yeah Europe in the Middle East
they just [ __ ] straight-up take yeah
and I feel like it and I feel like in
the US and the 70s it was kind of like
he kind of did it and everybody talked
about it and it wasn't well they didn't
have like a black PR campaign about it
yeah you know I mean it wasn't a shame
about her or like oh you know that's
cheating it's not cheating you still
gotta lift that weight yeah it's not
like you just take it take it away a bit
yeah no you just steroids just help you
heal up all that damage that you're
doing by lifting yeah all the tearing up
all that now the body's response is to
heal up quickly and then grow yeah I
mean which it yeah makes it easier you
couldn't do that without it you'd be
spending all the time healing well yeah
because when you don't take the stare I
mean you can really only work out hard
after you're healed in everything every
few days you know it's not betting on
your age depending on how old and on how
old you are [ __ ] good steroids you
can tick you could have met okay there's
something there like people have to
understand if you don't have much muscle
mass in other words your muscles are
small you can workout and you will get
sore quickly very quickly and you don't
have to lift real heavy weight but
because you don't have much muscle mass
it recovers and grows back very quickly
because it's not much muscle to repair
if you got big muscles you got a [ __ ]
lift a lot of weight it's gonna be very
intense and it [ __ ] [ __ ] up that
muscle it gets it real so it'll be sore
later right well it's still the same
you're still the same metabolism but now
you got to heal up 30 times the amount
of muscle that a little skinny person
has to heal up that's very taxing on the
system so instead of recovering in two
days it might take a week or eight days
to heal all that up well you don't have
time for that you'll get smaller you
know I mean you've got to be healed up
in 12 hours or 24 hours to get back in
there and do it again inside that gym
that's where all this you know gain in
20 pounds over what your maximum genetic
limit is that's where that's all coming
from yeah
the ability to heal everything and to
grow constantly so the bigger you are
the more weight you need the more sore
you're gonna get and the longer it's
gonna take to heal that up you need the
steroids to [ __ ] reduce that recovery
time yeah I feel like that's probably
largely what they're using up or yeah
yeah it's recovery yeah when those guys
are [ __ ] jacked to the gills man they
can go in there and just tear it all up
the whole body go to sleep 12 hours
later they're ready to do two yet yeah
not only did they heal up they've gotten
bigger slightly so you can't do that
with a normal metabolism yeah not with
that much muscle mass sure so this
shifts like [ __ ] Super Soldier Serum
it's like it's like that damn machine
Captain America came out of it
little skinned hitting a BAM like that
except you have to lift weights to do it
and it happens fast supernaturally fast
you know yeah so it's not normal yeah so
I do feel a hell of a drug though yeah
well think of it think of that yeah
think of the logistics of that how much
healing is happening and growing it's
it's amazing
it's why they give it to people who get
hurt yeah yeah well and that was I mean
the what is this the widespread use of
stage
in the 1970s was kind of what
contributed to you know through the 80s
and 90s and stuff like that like the
[ __ ] particularly the mr. Olympia
competition the focus becoming more on
just these huge dudes like people just
getting bigger and bigger bigger because
I guess they were trying to push the
envelope of like how how large they
could get you know with the steroid
enhancement you know the biggest one
they ever got during that time was in
the 90s you got [ __ ] huge late-night
Ronnie Coleman yeah I was he was on the
Dinah Coleman gut he proved his [ __ ]
point I respected his game he won eight
times I think in a row he got big as a
[ __ ] car he's huge but you don't I
mean just because you have all that
muscle and you have to lift all that
weight to tear it up so you can grow
it's not good on your skeleton I mean
you know that guy's spine is just shot
yeah you know I feel sorry for me last
time I saw he can barely walk he's
trying to and he'll never be as big as
he was you know it's fun to get big but
then having to get small again and then
he's in there working out and he's
nowhere near as big as he used to be
because cuz of you know I mean I
skeletal problems and just his system is
[ __ ] up he might recover it will take
a long time probably but he'll never be
as big as he was I mean a human being
can't be that big he was one of the
first guys to really because like I said
I'm pretty sure if I'm remembering it
correctly I'm pretty sure that he won
mr. Olympia eight years in a row yeah
and he was one of the first guys to push
the 300 pound limit it was amazing I
mean you had guys like you know in the
70s you had Schwarzenegger and stuff
like that in the 80s you had like Lee
Haney and people like that then in the
1990s you start seeing like Ronnie
Coleman Dorian Yates like he's really
really huge dudes like I said getting up
to like 280 290 pounds yeah which was
like unprecedented you know the problem
is is that they looked they looked
pretty good on stage doing a doing a
routine you put clothes on them and they
look funny yeah you know they they
looked real short
big old Loompas they weren't aesthetic
yeah like in the way already all look
good and close to you know and it's just
when your that's when you're as big as
Ronnie Coleman and [ __ ] you're gonna
look funny and close just say it yeah
and that's what we were saying before
it's like once you get to a certain
point it becomes strange-looking
yeah and not you know it doesn't really
look all that attractive it's what the
judges were picking though oh yeah
because it really did seem like
throughout I mean a lot of the people
that they interviewed for this
particular documentary and it's on
youtube if you're gonna watch it it's
BBC it's just called history of
bodybuilding I think and it's almost 2
hours long and I feel like a lot of
people were saying that the 90s were
probably you know the the heyday of mr.
Olympia and all that kind of stuff but
then like it started getting too much
too much focus on size and not really
you know they were getting away from the
focus on like people that actually
looked good that were like symmetrical
that actually like looked aesthetically
pleasing yeah another thing that's funny
about this era that we're talking about
in bodybuilding it was a lot like the
same era of in during that same era the
same thing was happening to martial arts
yeah you could make money with a dojo
and going to competitions and then you
could make money with magazines and you
know I mean and and like conventions but
over time social media destroyed all
that like magazines are gone black belt
magazine yeah I mean it probably has 20
pages now and probably nobody buys it
black belt magazine probably doesn't
exist well there used to be a whole
bunch of fitness magazines that's all
gone and muscle muscle magazines all
gone yeah it flexes and a lot of the
same stuff that was going on
in the bodybuilding scene that generated
a lot of money like these guys started
to wane a lot because at all with social
media yeah well you know they don't need
to do that any
or they can just go on Instagram and
take videos of themselves and sell [ __ ]
of supplements and [ __ ] through
Instagram you know they don't need
magazines or anything anymore
so it's just everything's changed yeah
it really what it used to be like a huge
big deal like the big business big
companies and big big sponsors behind it
but you needed magazines for all that
you know that's you know that's all gone
yeah so it's all social media some have
said that it's actually bigger now that
it used to be because of social media
it's just that the money's democracy
democracy now yeah it's like not as it's
not centralized in these companies yeah
but you know I can see that and that
that's one thing that they were talking
about the end of the documentary which
like I said came out in 2015 and they
were talking about how a lot of the
competition's had gone online so people
were watching them like streaming and
stuff like that so they still have like
a large audience and there's like a lot
of people still doing that and the prize
money is still very is it's still a lot
yeah but and instead of like you know
watch an Arnold Duke commando or Conan
the Barbarian and watching these guys in
action flicks you could now just watch
them on YouTube [ __ ] talking [ __ ]
about each other and [ __ ] making
jokes they all got their own channels
and [ __ ] yeah so they're not in movies
anymore they're all are youtubers kind
of fascinating how it evolved yeah but
they're making their own content yeah
you don't need camera crewmen or you
know you don't need movies to make money
off of being a muscular dude just get
subscribers and patrons well yeah as
long as you got like [ __ ] some media
savvy and you're gonna like charismatic
and stuff yeah it's kind of like reality
TV yeah and like I said it's like
there's some people you know like models
and [ __ ] like that on Instagram yeah
they're making [ __ ] tons of money on
histogram models I mean not all of them
are obviously no but the ones we're
making do it yes and that's all that's
what a supermodel made anyway yeah and
and the supermodel wasn't around for
very long back of the day lucky would be
a year to some of
like an Instagram models and make a
million dollars around four or five six
years or not longer yeah so yeah that's
the thing I feel like Schwarzenegger
obviously he was probably taking
steroids in the seventies because
everyone was yeah he was um and like I
said they were weren't really
stigmatized back then he but he actually
wouldn't admit to it until after he had
retired yeah you know what I mean he all
he would say was that oh well you know
you have to do anything to win the
competition that's kind of like all he
would say you can see pictures up as a
teenager he's obviously on gear yeah but
it's like it's it's weird that he
wouldn't say that runs on it until like
later on and then he was like yeah and
then he just said that later that he was
glad that he took at her he didn't
regret taking anything but he just like
wouldn't admit to it that maybe was she
never would have been famous so they
started doing um so the IFBB they
started instituting like you know doping
tests and stuff like that um even though
I'm sure like a lot of bodybuilders
probably a way to get around that
because a lot of them still take
steroids I just go off cycle get it all
out of your system that's yeah I think
that's technically what they're doing
yet because as far as I'm aware now
according to the wikipedia page it said
that the anabolic steroid Control Act
was 1990 so anabolic steroids are
technically in schedule three of the
Controlled Substances Act meaning that
they're not technically I guess there
are controls so there's controlled
substance so it's like you can't just
buy them like over the counter you can't
just buy them you have to have like a
prescription yeah blah but you know
that's the thing of what some
competitions have I mean obviously there
are some bodybuilding competitions for
like you know natural bodybuilders and
you know you can't take them for that
but I kind of feel like a lot of them
just do it anyway you know what I mean
and they just have some way to get
around it it's just kind of like people
that you know they have all these drug
tests for jobs and [ __ ] like that but
there's all this like there's all these
ways to get around it you then they
don't really test yeah
it's like you give pretend attend they
you give them like someone else's
no it could be that the organization's
don't test yeah they might I don't these
guys yeah those guys that run those
organizations don't give a [ __ ] about
steroids they were all on them and yeah
that's wrong like there's so much money
in it yeah like and particularly like
during the time when they just wanted to
see how big these dudes could get and
like that's what was bringing in the
Bucks I feel like why would they want to
shoot themselves in the dick like that I
don't believe in any of that anti
steroid thinking but you know I mean
those dudes all know what they're doing
they all know what the risks are I think
they're free to take you need that [ __ ]
yeah I don't that doesn't make any
difference to me
yeah if they want to do it then do it
all they're doing is [ __ ] with their
hormones basically women have been
[ __ ] with their hormones and birth
control forever so they don't have kids
it's basically that simple yeah anything
that's the thing it's like if you're
gonna go that far it's like Oh men can't
[ __ ] with their testosterone then you
gotta say a women can't have fun can't
take Burton yeah that's what it's all
this yeah so that same things that's
pretty much they says pretty much the
same thing so I don't understand what
while that why there's a problem with it
I could understand you don't want
dumbass kids getting their hands on it
no D in on it but the thing is is that
they OD on other [ __ ] anyway well then
the thing is we have Laura it's like you
know you can't have like underage
drinking like you know people drink
underage but you're not supposed to yeah
and you'll get in trouble if you do it
yeah it's like yeah you know you can
have laws like that to keep [ __ ] from
getting into like the hands of kids and
[ __ ] but if you're an adult you know and
you have made an informed decision about
you know what the side effects are and
all that other kind of crap then I don't
bro yeah I don't really see a problem
with people doing that to their own
bodies I heard one dude say III know
that this might shorten my lifespan but
I'm gonna give up a few years of life in
exchange for a much better quality of
life I said I want to feel better I'm
gonna be bigger I like to be big in this
in it makes me feel good I'm gonna do it
and ya know so he knew the risks and I'm
like go ahead man you look good go ahead
well yeah I mean I don't really you know
it's just kind of like anything that if
it's not hurting another
person this is right and it's your own
body yeah and like I said you're making
an informed decision you know what the
side effects of the [ __ ] is you know
what it's gonna do you know all this
other stuff and you choose to take it
anyway and there's nothing the matter
with you or anything like that then I
don't see any reason why you shouldn't
its biotechnology yeah we we take all
kinds of other drugs to extend extend
that the quality of our life and make
our lives [ __ ] you know better or
longer you know I mean insulin you know
what I mean to treat diabetes right
there's all this other [ __ ] you can do
why can't you take something that makes
you stronger yeah it's just how is that
wrong I mean and everything has you
everything has side effects even [ __ ]
aspirin has side effects are some people
yeah but there's no where are you gonna
draw the line there yeah they're willing
they're willing to take those side
effects though yeah
that's what I'm saying and why can't a
person volunteer to be like a research
subject on [ __ ] biotechnology why
can't a guy say you know what I've never
taken steroids before but now that I'm
50 what would what would therapeutic
doses of steroids do over the next
thirty years will it soften the blow of
my aging yeah you know I want to try do
you know they passed that right to try
bill for all you know you might stumble
on some kind of a damn life extension
therapy yeah you know I mean because
geriatrics lose a lot of muscle mass
they would get weak and they weaken and
they die [ __ ] like that might actually
strengthen you you might die still at 95
or 85 but who knows you might look
better well and you might have died
earlier than that anybody
there's nobody died 75 yeah there's no
way of knowing and what if you died at
85 but you looked like a 65 year old and
you were as strong as a [ __ ] 55 year
old that's still pretty good trade-off
yeah and for all you know like you said
maybe you maybe you extended your life
by a few years
yeah there's no way of knowing but why
not be involved in human testing yeah
you know particularly once you get to a
particular age your old already yeah
where it's just kind of like I I can't
feel like if they want to do whatever
the [ __ ] they want to do cuz they're
like hey I only got 20 30 years left
anyway the scene will just see what this
does and if something and you know and
if this is a good thing and it could
benefit other people also because they
might find some [ __ ] out with it and
they can apply it to other people like
they were just talking about the first
dude that they send to Mars might be an
old man and it's a one-way trip yeah you
know I mean what's the difference cuz
you know you only got a few years left
anyway
you know you might at least spend your
last 10 years on Mars doing [ __ ] yeah
you know you're gonna die anyway doing
[ __ ] on and you want to be there for
that last 10 years yeah man so that's
usually gets people to volunteer for
that they were talking about it yeah I
would think and you know sure there'd be
guys go yeah I'll go yeah that I don't
have any family only got 10 yeah I'll go
to your ball go to Mars that's what I
mean you know I just don't really see
why go out let it go out in a blaze yeah
you know tell everybody remember every
remember you yeah first man on Mars oh
man oh man oh boy that's gravity
oh man Omar I'm gonna make it he sure
it's just like the surface of Mars that
like this little gute oh man a space
helmet on space helmet on flex in space
plan an American flag in the ground
[Laughter]
one-way trip [ __ ] oh man on Mars them
yeah one-way trip all the [ __ ] shirts
we come up with for the show and I never
get a rented design it's never a video
but it's like it's just it's it's funny
to me to think that if like somebody
wore that shirt and it's like no one
would have any [ __ ] place that's like
the most inside of in such yeah alright
so like I said so so they have the thing
where you know they they do the drug
testing or at least they say they do
even though I don't believe it because
I've seen the last dudes at one mr.
Olympia there's like there's no way they
weren't taking steroids but they do have
now does the mr. Olympia competition
because I wasn't clear on this do they
have an
natural bodybuilding I don't know
anything or is that like a whole
separate competition because they have
like they have like all these different
bodybuilding outfits and they each have
their own competition yeah that you can
compete in and like some of them like
the natural bodybuilding ones you're not
supposed to take anything - to tell you
the truth really when I hear about the
history of bodybuilding and like the
[ __ ] the the professional shows and
everything only the ones from the
seventies sound interesting to me and
that was before my time
yeah cuz by the time I was old enough to
even know what the [ __ ] was going on in
the 90s that scene wasn't cool
yeah it like the masked monsters and
[ __ ] I didn't think anything they looked
that good see I didn't and I can't even
really can't nobody really cared about
and that's what I thought see when I was
watching the documentary like the
earlier [ __ ] I found like really really
interesting yes I'm indeed yeah but then
it does seem like now because I think
that the mr. Olympia competition they
may have a natural category for sure
they have a men's physique category they
added that in 2013 yeah which that's
just that was people that was a direct
reaction to the mass monster phenomenon
where everyone was saying that looks
like ugly and we're getting away from
what mr. Olympia started as was the
whole it was supposed to be like an
aesthetic ya know a symmetrical like a
you know a beautiful kind of like a
representation of manhood right and it's
getting into this thing where everybody
just looks like these big lumpy ogres
yeah you know you're supposed to look
like a damn superhero right that's what
you're a hood ornament slash superhero
yeah and by the time the nineties had
rolled around that that wasn't around
anymore and it wasn't a very popular
scene and there wasn't any kind of like
like household personalities that were
driving that scene you know in about in
other words you couldn't associate it
with anybody that you knew right yeah
Maliki the 70s he knew Arnold and you
knew Lou and you know Franco Columbu you
knew who those guys were
yeah
and they had character you know
especially you know Arnold I don't had a
lot of character but by the time the 90s
are around you know there wasn't it yeah
I feel like after the nineties that kind
of like fell off there weren't any like
there was no cure at ik person because
it yeah there weren't any like
celebrities out of the field that came
out that like everybody knew even if you
didn't know anything about that
particular right you need to have some
kind of celebrity face or some kind of
celebrity character to make you kind of
even be interested in that competition
so you see was he gonna win you know
yeah but by the time nineties roll ride
it was kind of like nobody really gave a
[ __ ] well it's just kind of like any
sport you really kind of need at least
one person who's like celebrity status
that everybody knows who it is yeah you
know the same ones you have like Michael
Jordan or somebody like that where
everybody if you don't give a [ __ ] about
that sport everybody knows who the [ __ ]
that is and I feel like after
Schwarzenegger after Lou Ferrigno stuff
like that I feel like it kind of fell
off and nobody really nobody who wasn't
into that it was like super into that
particular sport yeah and the 2000s to
2010's it was just like off the radar
and I think they had a lot to do at the
war yeah because you know what I mean
you had 9/11 happened and the war
happened and everybody was [ __ ] really
paying attention what was going on with
their like the war on terror you weren't
really you know anyone really didn't
give a [ __ ] what was having a
bodybuilders at that time that's what I
mean I'm sure you still they're still
like the [ __ ] you know hardcore people
that are here to it but not civilians
but it not like a widespread no and even
it it's even pretty niche as far as like
other sport and there wasn't no and
there wasn't social media or anything
online during that time to look at so
yeah it dependent on Hollywood and
television and [ __ ] so that first so for
the average person I think that was kind
of just like a dark period you know but
I think really the future of that scene
is all gonna be social media-driven I
think it's given it new life
actually yeah I think now I think maybe
new new things will appear but you're
still have that same kind of guy yeah
now
women are into it yeah that's a very
that's a very growing yeah thank you
and honestly um the interesting thing
about what we were just talking about
about the men's physique category that
started in 2013 they said they actually
started out kind of slow but now it's
kind of like the most popular category
that's one you were talking about before
where they have the board shorts yeah oh
sure they don't have the little you know
a little swim trunks or anything so
that's kind of like become the most
popular category so they're seeing that
as kind of a trend more back toward the
roots of the competition's know sort of
where they're going back to you to like
actually looking good and like looking
not necessarily natural but like looking
more aesthetically pleasing rather than
yeah it's it's close to to classic
physique right class of busy they were a
little more top-heavy than that but it's
close to it yeah because men's physique
and classic physique are two different
classes yeah
I'm not entirely sure I think classic
physique is kind of like in the middle
like the men's for classes or the
archetype of classic physique could be
Arnold yeah pretty big but not you know
not huge thighs not a mass monster
you're looking for a six pack or four
pack something like that you don't I
mean you have to be able to do a vacuum
pose look good front double bicep you
know you know it's just that was your
seventies classic for the guys from the
70s that's why they look yeah
mints fitness is thinner than that yeah
being cut I mean okay so the classes are
they have men's physique that's the
smallest bodybuilders and they have the
board shorts and then you got classic
physique which is kind of like heaven in
the middle and they kind of have boxer
shorts on and then you got your
bodybuilder like the main mr. Olympia
yeah I think they call it like open
class or something like
like the biggest one so there's like
real massive yeah the classic physique
didn't start till 2016 so that's only
been going a couple of years but like I
said it really does seem like it's
trending more toward where they started
that we're trying where they're trying
to get it to look more like back in the
70s like I said are more like a
classical physique routing much just
these big pretty much every important
channel that I watch they're all talking
about we got to get back to the classic
physique and they're talking yeah
another talked about but I think that's
the best look yeah because like I said
and it wasn't just like you know dumb
asses like me that don't know anything
about the [ __ ] saying that they thought
that you know these big roided-out dudes
were like it was just gross looking or
like freakish looking a lot of people
that were in the sport they're saying
we're saying the same thing they were
just like this is just getting out of
hand and it's like it doesn't even look
good and they were getting something
called bubble gut to Colombo ISM cuz
there's named every [ __ ] day for long
ago who had it and they're [ __ ] their
[ __ ] bellies would be like a total
round bubble on a [ __ ] huge [ __ ]
dude he's totally ripped and the bubbles
even got like a six-pack or anything but
it's still a bubble and it looks like a
[ __ ] half a basketball and it hurt
and no one really knew why Yeah right
well you know there was all these
theories of why they were doing that it
must have been some kind of a drug they
were taken or a side-effect from like
very extreme levels of some kind of
steroid one theory that I heard ok this
would be good yeah this guy was all
[ __ ] day Palumbo Show Palumbo's
wouldn't his name he had it they named
it he said this [ __ ] to the wrong yes he
had a guest on who was talking about
bubble gut didn't call for lumber with
Palumbo is ibly called it a bubble guy
but he's like you know what I'm talking
yeah you know everybody goes
I have a theory what that was and Davis
listening right and he goes I think it
was and he goes these hormones these
steroids that guys were taken from that
time you know they were coming from
China and it was actually it was being
extracted from rats and rat you know rat
hormones because if you look at a rat
they got a [ __ ] bubble god on him you
know I mean they've always got these
stuff so they're coming like a plumber
goes no I don't think that's what it is
that made me [ __ ] laugh I gotta phone
the animals you're gonna pick it's like
it did have like a beer gut rat is not
the first one I would think if you look
at a rat it's got a [ __ ] around and it's
kind of looking like that I like it like
the gut of a rat so you kind of become
one kind of rat like because that's
where it was coming from that's you know
and I don't remember exactly where he
said it was coming for something for
some kind of gland that came out of a
rat they were baked up becoming kind of
rat like and [ __ ] Dave is like no I
disagree he thought it was something
else that I think might have been a
swelling of internal organs may be made
that [ __ ] Yanks wouldn't that be
scared it may be something like that or
maybe be like the livers getting a
little bit swollen it tastes pregnant
with a demon child they were taking a
lot more steroids than guys too back in
the in the 70s during classic physique
so yeah once you start pushing those
boundaries and I mean it was a kind of
unknown you would think that maybe
growth hormones and steroids would try
to grow you out of what your normal
[ __ ] shape should be well that's a
big no-no like where shits gonna start
yeah and they were taking us to a
certain point and they were taking a
whole stack of [ __ ] all at the same time
you know you could start throwing a
[ __ ] thing out of your head yeah in
the stack that they were taking was like
like secret they don't want to tell the
other competition of what it was they
were taking right so there's no talent
if you were taking 12 different things
and all of them
kind of bad you wouldn't be able to tell
what what you wouldn't know what cause
that that could be a million different
things our interactions between tanks
yep so but it did happen with some of
those guys in that era get this little
bubble gut and you can just google it
right there these two they'll talk about
it on YouTube I'm not gonna bubble gun
or Columbo is it yeah they're [ __ ]
lipped it's like a round bubble gun is
ripped you can see the [ __ ] six-pack
unit they should be funny and just like
wear maternity clothing just own it you
know don't say I'm gonna do and be just
like it ripped everywhere it used to be
like like a basketball coming out he's
doing it yeah so there is also like I
said it's you know they don't talk too
much about female bodybuilding cuz
they're just girls and everything but
they did actually have a Miss Olympia
that started in nineteen back in 1980
yeah and they also did a punk I love
this okay so in 1985 they did pumping
iron to the women yeah that's what it
was called a lot of those female body
goes yeah a lot of this email what
bodybuilders didn't turn out well they
ended up with beards and mustaches and
[ __ ] start taking [ __ ] you take
enough testosterone without steroids you
will turn into a man yeah no thank you
they found him later on and they look
they're like little men they stop taking
they get all shrunken and [ __ ] and then
they had one that they saw a photograph
of her she used to be huge she's
shrunken look like a little skinny old
man with a [ __ ] mustache and a beard
wearing men's clothing because she just
figured well [ __ ] you became a man might
as well I guess she just became a man
but that's they're not really female
bodybuilders aren't doing it like they
used to do it back in those days yeah I
feel like they kind of tried to do for
wonder they were like ya know the idea
is to look more feminine now yeah that's
the Instagram model big booty boobs
maybe some you know maybe some upper
body strength and I think they're doing
a lot better I think you know I mean I
a woman's really just not built just
weight a lot of this we may look like a
[ __ ] bodybuilder male
yeah and I feel like a lot of the female
bodybuilding competitions I don't know
about the MS Olympia contest but they
have more of like an athletic component
to them like they do gymnastics and [ __ ]
like that
yeah it's so it's not just posing so I
you know I do feel like yeah that is
like presumably like you know like I
said I'm not judging it they got Musa do
that [ __ ] to their body but it's no they
got kind of a new style of just gym rat
girl she's just got big legs big boobs
dressed up like Chumlee or something
doing karate kicks and [ __ ] like a
buck are Nike or whatever name is you
know what the [ __ ] long tongue and
the black eyes it looks good you know
she's so sexy though she looks like a
woman yeah yeah I mean it's just you
[ __ ] around with a lot of those [ __ ]
performance hansung drugs and a lot of
testosterone you do too much of it
you're just gonna be a dude yeah you
know that's gender has a lot to do with
[ __ ] biochemistry and that's what
you're [ __ ] with you know so there's
limits you know I mean so I I kind of
like the direction a lot of the
Instagram fitness model girls are going
now they they're they're trying to
instead of looking masculine they're
trying to look hyper-feminine yeah you
know I mean like a superhero female type
what they're trying to look for you know
yeah I can see how that would be it
looks a lot better yeah cuz I don't know
I wouldn't look like a dude yeah and if
you go back to the [ __ ] 78 and go
back to the 90s and the 80s mostly the
90s the bodybuilders female bodybuilders
of the 90s they didn't look good I
didn't think yeah it was a long strange
like it yeah but I feel like it had like
less of you know you whereas it seemed
like it took like 20 or 30 years for
like the dudes just to get bigger and
bigger bigger before they finally were
like yeah this doesn't look so good
where I feel like the women we're kind
of like they got bigger and they're like
I have [ __ ] this it didn't really
experience yeah they were just like did
it for like a couple of years yeah
but they got ways to do it now you know
they able to still look like women yeah
you know yeah it can't be done it's just
you know like I said I I would not I
would not be gonna be a lot of lower
body work and stuff yeah I I would not
be super into like taking testosterone
or anything like that so we've got a
Chinese girl does justice up like
chun-li for summer photographs like that
girl from the video game and has thighs
just like that I don't know how much of
it is photoshopped though because they
some of those photos are very deceptive
I'm looking at it my god that looks like
Photoshop dude do you know yeah like
that waist can't be that skinny you know
so there's just certain things I can
draw you know I'm pretty good artist too
I haven't drawn in a long time there's
some proportions that you know are
impossible well from that angle if it's
that wide then if you turn it around and
that means is that you know that waist
is this big around I said it's some
really really bad photo shops of like
yeah chicks that don't know how to cuz
I'm a graphic designer happen for
20-something years right so I've been
using Photoshop for two decades and I
know but I've seen some shitty Photoshop
I've seen a good photo shop too but you
can still tell what it's fake yeah so do
you want to talk about bulking and
cutting or anything like that
or do you want to talk about cuz
remember I think it was on last week's
show or on one of the side tracks show
you said you left a cliffhanger and you
said you were gonna talk about whether
you were natural or not no no actually
technically I was natural from my whole
life up into a month ago yeah yeah I
took some sarbs yeah yeah but you know
some people would say well then you're
not natural I'm I'm enhanced and it just
taken taken they're not steroids they're
no they're like ya know song almost kind
of like a hologram of a spirits a lot of
people laugh at him yeah guys who take
roids laugh at [ __ ] sarbs because uh
if they took sorry wouldn't do anything
to him yeah
they're already [ __ ] big but if
you've never taken any steroids you can
takes arms and get some kind of speeds
up your healing at my age and if you're
young I'm not sure I look at the
photographs of young guys they've taken
saw arms and working out and the the
results didn't look too impressive to me
yeah but me at 50 take an austere eeen
I've noticed that I heal up a lot faster
yeah you did you say heal up a lot
faster and let's just leave it at that
yeah I don't think I don't think what's
a good way to put it I don't think
they're for everybody but I think for
older people stuff like Austrian is
gonna be advantageous yeah I heal up
faster on it but the thing with all
those Psalms and what makes them
different from steroids is that with a
steroid you can actually exceed your
genetic potential you can put on another
20 pounds that you could never get all
right nah ass arm won't do that a psalm
will help you get closer to your genetic
potential but you'll never break it
right no dama so it's kind of like a
safer alternative or like a more yeah
well it depends on which one yeah bunch
of different ones and it depends on who
you ask
people who sell steroids and there are
doctors that sell steroids will say no
it's the same risks as a steroids might
as well buy mine we know those work you
know I mean so um it's difficult to say
yeah I mean it's they're not an illegal
drug they're actually not really
approved for human use they're
considered to be a research chemical
well yeah there are no human trials yeah
they're inhuman triose tureen is the one
that's the closest to being approved
that's the one I'm taking and you know
just take a standard dose no I don't
[ __ ] go crazy with it or anything
it's just and notice instead of healing
up in five days I'll heal up in two so
that's yeah because I mean you were
doing like you you lift like really
heavy weights but you were like leaving
like several days in between like 45
days image taken too long to heal up
yeah
yeah because sometimes it would be like
now if I was on steroids [ __ ] at my
age I'm in good health I could do a
cycle innate in 18 months I could
[ __ ] make like ten years of progress
yeah but the thing is is that you come
off of those and I don't know that's a
lot of muscle you not have to maintain I
don't know I don't know it's just us a
little early in my journey you don't I
mean I don't think I don't think I'm
ready for it let's just see how it goes
yeah I don't want to be that big I just
want to be [ __ ] healthy yeah you're
not really doing it for competition
promises or because you want to be like
a gigantic monster you just want to like
be in good shape in the shape and
maintain strength and fit and maintain
my resistance to disease help kind of
soften the blow of Aging
you know after 50 that 50 to 60
sometimes is a steep decline for a lot
of guys yeah I've done the research if
you're lifted alright
that [ __ ] decline is not as
pronounced yeah there are guys you know
like Chet Jordan who claims to be
natural which I bet think he might be
mostly natural maybe he had some help
later on in years he's an old guy man
he's gotta be semi something years old
and he looked good looks real good he's
lifted his whole life yeah yeah so Jack
LaLanne looked pretty good for his whole
life I don't know how I don't know if he
was natural you see sometimes sometimes
you might see a guy he looks really fit
got like Jack LaLanne I can tell you
right now he wasn't a full-on [ __ ]
roid
yeah monster you know what I mean but he
might have done small doses of it so you
know is that natural technically no but
that's enhanced yeah but could he have
done that [ __ ] without it maybe maybe
not but have it been a lot harder
probably without it yeah I don't
remember him being a gigantic dude no
nobody was well proportioned cut and he
was strong his whole life
when he was old he was strong he lived
into his nineties didn't yeah cuz I
remember I think he was like selling
that [ __ ] juicer on the way doing
[ __ ] a long long time yeah I'm pretty
sure he was in his nineties well I got a
feeling he wasn't a hundred percent
natural I had got a feeling that he was
taking therapeutic cycles of positive
steroids probably like real light cycles
of it and probably in because of you
know society at that time he probably
didn't say anything about it yeah but
[ __ ] that's life extension he lived a
long time yeah and was healthy the hole
the hole you know pretty much yeah
because even when he was like a really
old man looking he's in good shape and
[ __ ] yeah
so how was that bad yeah that's what I
mean it's like really how's that bad
yeah I gotta be reasonable he lived to
be [ __ ] 90 something years old
mm-hm and was [ __ ] strong the whole
way through that how is that bad how did
that hurt him
yeah not it didn't yeah and he was still
like real active yeah into his nightly
home but I remember and he still had all
his faculties when I was a little kid he
was old yeah and he looks great
yeah and there's like at that time
[ __ ] you know backness em he's one of
the one of the [ __ ] strongest
best-looking guys on television and he
was already an old man yeah I do
was he a hundred percent natural
probably not probably not looking back
on it now probably not yeah so you know
he was on to something there I guess so
and I don't think it was the [ __ ]
juice either no how could you say but
like I said there's a difference between
use and abuse right he I kind of
suspected there are guys like that that
will therapeutically use to kind of
[ __ ] tell pics it's like that spice
but that's the thing I mean and like I
said that's kind of the thing about
anything is that you know anything is
bad if you take to a lot of it right
[ __ ] even if you drink too much water it
will kill if you're Ronnie Coleman and
you're [ __ ]
just down in that [ __ ] yeah you're gonna
get [ __ ] up but who's to say you're
not Jack LaLanne and you just taking
little bangs here and there you know I
mean went to help [ __ ] rebuild some
[ __ ] and defection you know keep
yourself going and it's kind of like the
[ __ ] the elixir of aitai from [ __ ]
what was that [ __ ] the the fiendish
plot of doctor that was random he's
trying to get that [ __ ] elixir of a
vitai we didn't you have to get freaked
out and out of women didn't he ah is he
extracted energy extracted it out of
[ __ ] people you know and he got y'all
man that was like that [ __ ] movie the
leech woman that was yesterday science
theater - she was but she had to get I
think it was a pituitary gland wasn't it
she had the ring and she had to get it
it had to be men though she would get
like the juice out of their pituitary
gland and she would drink it and then
that kept her young except then at the
end spoiler alert she gets it out of a
woman because she started getting
desperate cuz she started cuz it didn't
last she would stay young and then like
a little while later she start getting
like super old again like really quickly
so then she had to like kill a woman
because a woman was just like right
there and she was available so she's
like you know plug her and then when she
took the woman's pituitary juice then at
made her age like super quickly and then
she died yeah so you know so was that a
thing like Bacchus cos when that when
they figured out like what pituitary
glands were and then cuz suddenly it
seems like there were all these movies
where that was a plot point yeah well
that's when they figured out what
steroids and testosterone yeah [ __ ]
Super Soldier Serum and [ __ ] you know
and America yeah ROI and it'll keep you
young they're talking about see I'm very
skeptical
it's very skeptical of the medical
industry you know hooking
I worked for dr. Matt and you know I'm a
friend Steve [ __ ] you know he'll is
sick and going for his doctorate he's a
biochemist that medicine is about making
profits it's it's these are companies
you know they don't they want to sell
expensive treatments you know the last
thing they want to do is cure diabetes
alright cuz they make a [ __ ] ton of
money off of treating diabetes and
that's just the way it is they're not
they're not in you know trying to cure
diseases alright and if you're poor the
last thing they want you to do is to
live longer well yeah okay that's that's
the idea rich people yeah they live a
long time you notice that yeah what a
rich that could be yeah and what they're
doing I like my ass it doesn't it has
health insurance for years yeah I said
my health insurance plan is don't get
sick and if you do just ignore it until
it gets okay they had all kinds of weird
fad material they evidently had these
weird companies that would pop up to
where they would [ __ ] take rich
people and [ __ ] fly to your house and
land their chopper at your chopper pad
and you could sit up there and they
[ __ ] transfuse you with blood from
teenagers with all that damn [ __ ]
hormones and [ __ ] keep you going that's
like some [ __ ] of debt it's like some
[ __ ] that a [ __ ] vampire yeah when
these doctors when these doctors go to
med school and everything you know a lot
of them you know you're talking about
kind of betas kind of guys you know me
they're not into making [ __ ] big
dudes that'll beat them up in high
school or anything they're not like that
you know I mean they're just trying to
cure diseases and make money for these
medical and [ __ ] companies they're
not into making things that make thing
make people stronger or faster or live
lager that's that's not in there they're
not into that all right so some of this
stuff idea reticle II in my mind it's
not just me other guys are thinking this
that there's stuff out there that if you
used it in therapeutic doses might might
extend life yeah we're not talking about
like one that'll like make you live
forever no but just like taking little
bits of it will probably like improve or
at least improve your life yeah but who
knows you look at Jack LaLanne let's say
he was using therapeutic doses as a
doses of [ __ ] you know gear what
would happen if he didn't do that what
he
died at 70 instead of 90 yeah and what
you've gotten real weak at around 60
something and been frail it's at 60 see
ya there there is an impact they know
that [ __ ] works they know it works yeah
you can demonstrate that it works but
they don't talk about how it works on
old people do it yeah not really
and then the guys that were abusing it
early on in life a lot of them never
made it to be old people yeah what
happens if they just were fit and
healthy yeah yeah up until about 50 all
right and then they started taking it
therapeutically at 50 because they were
healthy all right they weren't already
damaged by steroid abuse but then
therapeutic doses the steroids could you
run that out to 90 years old would it
extend your life am i I think it might
well I feel like if you're gonna do it
that seems like the way to do it because
it seems like the people that have the
most trouble are the ones that started
young and too high done and took high
doses of like for competitions and stuff
like that now some of those people like
was maintained and like still stay in
good shape but it does seem like a lot
of them had a lot of health problems
later on yeah but if you didn't take
anything until you were already like 50
or 55 and then you started taking it you
know and you were already in decent
shape like you've worked out and [ __ ]
like that prior to that but hadn't taken
anything but then you started taking
stuff in your 50s then that would
probably be the way to go I'm thinking
you know one thing is this it's
expensive but here in Florida it's easy
to get description for it and you see
TRT testosterone replacement therapy
they say it works wonders after 50 yea
which is similar to a steroid but you
can get all that [ __ ] at once but the
problem with it is that I heard that
here in this state they do it in a very
cookie-cutter fashion they don't even do
blood work to try to tailor a dosage to
you they just give you a standard dose
and what I'm thinking is what if you
took half of a standard dose see instead
of a standard doses of it it might be
even better to what we're talking about
this is all theory yeah like I said if
all you're trying to do is extend the
lines and life and make your life better
yeah you know what I mean so you don't
like decline yeah what happened he took
a quarter of a standard dice just you
know well it's probably better than
nothing right my thinking is is that you
should do as less as you as little as
you should possibly do yeah when you
think yeah that's it I would think as
little as possible yeah just enough like
I did have an effect yeah because if you
overdo it then that's more risk in my
cataract right it might counteract it I
mean I've always been a big not not out
of any kind of like moral obligation or
anything but I've I've just always tried
not to take anything yeah like just in
general you know I'll take aspirin but
yeah that's about it yeah I mean I don't
really like to take anything and I've
just been lucky that I've never gotten
really sick enough that I had to take
anything I had to take antibiotics a few
times for yeah that's pretty much it I
think how to take painkillers a few
times for surgery and whatnot but even
then I didn't even like take that much
of it so I'm real reluctant to take
anything unless I'm really really really
really hating life doctor already
precise prescribed me steroids
after that motorcycle accident yeah yeah
it's a long time ago just to get the
swelling down yeah it's good for that
yeah but that was it didn't gain you
muscle off of it wasn't working out well
yeah cuz you were laying around they're
all busted up yeah all right you done
talking about them done yeah
bodybuilders you done yeah I think we've
pretty much covered it we did the end
pretty much covered it I mean you know
there's a couple of recommendations if
you want to know more about it and the
history of bodybuilding then the
individual men that did the [ __ ] is real
interesting go check out Nick's
strength and power that's the name of
that channel it's on YouTube he's got a
whole playlist of like body pitted the
history
bodybuilding and the min by name of
everything that they did he gives user
stats and what they were like they
really that was a real interesting woman
another ones you could go check out
mister your key Fitness lover
I think or mister your key Fitness load
that's that's Leroy Colbert yeah find it
but Leroy old guys an old black guy and
he could tell you all these stories go
back in the 50s [ __ ] wonderful you
talk to your [ __ ] here off he just
died a couple years back he fell and hit
his head in his shop he had a bed foot
and he woke up in the hospital a few
times and said yeah I'll be all right
honey but then he he never came back
yeah that poor Leroy but he lived a long
life though if you want coaching I would
recommend Greg do set and he's on
YouTube - he got Solaris it sounds like
Gilbert Godfrey he'll take all your
Instagram models and all your [ __ ]
celebrities and Hills you know Nattie
are not natural or unnatural on he'll
[ __ ] tell you know this guy so I can
on this and that I know it is in it cuz
he can figure it out just by looking at
pictures you know he can he can tell you
who's odd geared who is it it's funny
all the shows are funny but yeah you
check out Greg Doucet he's pretty good
and you see that's about it yeah yes
about it yeah alright this it actually
this show ended up longer than I thought
I would get two hours of 40 minutes but
anyway yeah I know this is like a little
bit out of our usual wheelhouse but you
know this is something Thomson wanted to
do and I actually found it really
interesting when I started reading about
it you know yeah it's good yeah yeah I
thought it was entertaining so I hope
you guys have enjoyed it this was
episode 196 remember if you liked the
show like share subscribe on all your
social media if you'd like to
financially support the show it would be
much appreciated you can go to our
patreon page patreon.com/lenguin
we're pres calm
and there's a button in the sidebar that
goes to a PayPal account if you'd like
to give a one-time donation
we're also like I said eventually gonna
do the YouTube membership thing we just
haven't got around to putting it up yet
so but we'll get to that I promise and
oh and also I wanted to give a shout out
to when we were doing the break between
the show we got a PayPal donation from
Jason another one he always sends us a
very large generous PayPal donations
every now and then and we still have to
get him a shirt we are gonna do shirts I
swear to god we just haven't been out to
the store to get any prints I'm just
starting to get where it's going back to
normal we'll be out there in the next
couple yeah so the next probably in the
next week we're gonna go and like buy
supplies again for the next round of
shirts and we have to get a new design
go and [ __ ] like that so we'll get
everybody taken care of in the next
couple of weeks so that will do it for
episode 196 we will see you next time
bye
[Music]
you
[Music]